Hello 大家好 我是小俊。
今天我在上海唐化对象是英美达典救副总裁刘茗玉。
我们的唐化时间是黄仁勋刚刚访华之后的一个月。
茗玉给我的印象一直是穿着很朴素。
背着一个有点旧的鞋跨包 态度很铅合。
不过英美达内部的人告诉我。
他不像是一个典型的研究者 更像是一个工程上的领导者。
黄仁勋给他一个评价是 GSD Getting Sheets Down。
不久前 刘茗玉带领团队刚刚发布了英美达的世界模型 Cosmos3。
所以在这次访谈中 我们聊一聊 Cosmos3 世界模型。
同时也聊到一名研究者长达20年的求索。
而这名研究员的身份很特殊。
他身处在英美达这样一个基础设施型的巨大的系统之中。
这改变了他的很多的研究思路。
当然我们也很不自觉地聊了一些。
关于英美达和黄仁勋的内部的故事。
茗玉说做模型就要Low Eagle。
模型竞争不应该是一场由于游戏。
那接下来就是我对英美达研究副总裁刘茗玉的访谈。
就很常常在讲就是他喜欢这种 Zero Billion Dollar Business。
你可以是不赚钱
但当这个生意成功的时候 必须是很 Infantial 的 是很巨大的。
经济的冒赠程度是根据钱多块。
从一个人的口袋留到另外一个口袋。
研究的冒赠程度应该是根据。
Idea 的多块从一个人的脑袋留到另外一个人的脑袋去。
我们做完 Cosmos 1 的时候。
问这个Jensen 要不要继续往下做。
然后Jensen 跟我说 你就做到 Cosmos 19-17。
因为他是一个很有机率的人。
有些东西其实很重要。
他会叫你 Pace。
Pace Your Steps 让你不要急。
他擅长打麻辣松战。
他每天都觉得公司只剩下30天的现金流。
30天后就要破产。
你刚好加入英伟达10年了。
这10年你变化大吗？
你在英伟达的股票涨了多少倍了。
一股
Hello Mingyu 要不跟观众朋友们先打个招呼。
线上的朋友 大家好 我是刘明玉。
因为刚才我们也聊到你到美国了20年。
然后在英伟达了10年。
你现在讲中文还多吗 在公司里面。
就是有时候会讲中文。
但大部分时候还是讲英文。
因为大部分的时候 团队里。
还是很多人不会讲中文。
所以沟通上就是以英文为主。
但如果说在一个小组会议里面。
参与的都是讲中文的。
那很自然而然就会切换到中文模式。
这次你来中国的行程是什么样的。
你多久会来一次中国。
我现在大概是每一年会来2-3次中国。
因为我主要的公司给我的任务。
我个人的兴趣在Fysical AI。
在中国这里Fysical AI的发展是非常的冒胜。
很多公司 很多研究员都在做出重大的突破。
我们在这里跟大家交流也理解一下。
我们如何可以帮到他们。
这次来感觉到有什么不一样吗 跟之前。
这次来我看到的是。
越来越多的关于手 林桥手。
在关键的科技上面做出突破。
然后去追求下一个Fysical AI。
可以达到的一些重点能力。
就是跟上次来发觉就是速度非常的快。
进展非常的快
然后每次都学到很多东西。
这应该是你第一次做一个中文的Podcast。
我想能帮助观众或者听众朋友们建立一个印象。
你现在在英伟达的title是研究副总裁。
能不能介绍一下这个职位。
然后以及你们团队的一些构造和人数。
我现在是研究副总裁。
另外也是Cosmos Lab的副总裁。
那我们的团队呢？
就是研究员家工程师。
之属于我这里的大概有八九四人。
那另外公司还有其他的团队也是在做Cosmos。
英文叫Darty Delight。
虽然他不直接Report给我。
但是我是整个Mission的Overall Pick。
就是发号司令的人。
然后决定方向的人。
所以这些人也是就是遵循我的指示。
就是跟这个团队一起合作把目标给推出去。
整个过做Cosmos应该有两到三百人之间。
这是一个在英伟达里面很重大的一个。
一个转案
我们花很多资源
这样的人员投入是我们觉得需要的。
做出好的成果
我看到你之前还管一个团队叫。
Deep Imagination Research Group。
Cosmos是他演化来的吗？
他们是什么关系
是的
我大概是十年前的时候加入英伟达。
那我在加入英伟达的时候。
我的目标就是
我那时候给Job Talk。
在跟英伟达推销我自己的时候。
我的Job Talk讲的是。
那是十年前我讲的是说。
有一天最主要生成视频的运算。
将会是Deep Null。
而不会是传统的Computer Graphics。
在那时期就是电脑特效。
电影特效
用这种Graphics。
传统的Graphic Pipeline。
去生成漂亮的Graphics是主流。
然后我是在领域里面早期认为。
就是Deep Null是未来的趋势。
那我记得那时候
我跟我的Ship Scientist Bill Daddy。
在那时候的Presentation。
我的Presentation里面就是讲Deep Null。
因为它是Data Driven。
然后它可以做到很多传统Graphics。
可以做不到的事情。
比如说我有一天可以把。
就是小说
当成是Input。
放进这个Deep Null。
就可以产出电影
然后你可以做很多。
现在的Graphics需要大量人力。
才能做出来的这些控制。
那时候我
就是公司对这个东西很有兴趣。
我就很荣幸地加入了NVIDIA。
进去之后
我就一直朝着方向努力。
但那时期最主要的这个模型是。
Generative Adversary Network。
就是对抗声称网络。
那我是
只是林运理早期去。
从事这个对抗声称网络研究的人。
我就在里面一直做这方面的研究。
我做了几个
自己很感到骄傲的这个工作。
其中一个就是
我是最早提出这个可以做这种。
我们叫做
Unsupervised或是Umpair的Immit Translation。
在AI里面学习很多时候就靠Supervision。
你要对应的
Input跟Output。
你才可以学出这个Input Output Relationship。
那Unsupervised就是说。
你并没有对应的Input Output。
你并不知道这个人笑的时候是怎么样。
你不知道这个
这个码
变成斑马会是怎么样。
我们那时候是早期。
利用一些Information Battle Network。
可以去做出这个
我们叫Unsupervised Image to Image Translation。
那时候我加入英伟达的时候。
英伟达并不是一个。
大家认同的AI公司。
那时候Deep Nulling还没有像现在那么的火热。
英伟达传统也都是做这种。
Computer Architecture去设计这个。
GPU
没有人在做这种
比较应用端的科研。
我等于是早期在英伟达把这个方向做起来的。
我在做了许多东西。
其中一个work叫Goggin。
像中文码翻成马粮神笔。
像是小画家一样
图几个颜色
每个颜色代表不同的语意。
那你图一图之后
就可以变成漂亮的山水画。
内容work让我在。
等于是帮NVIDIA把。
建议起个形象
不只是可以做出很好的GPU。
也可以做出很好的AI模型。
那时候我还有一些同事。
在一起做style game方向的研究。
那我们就是这群人把NVIDIA从。
第一批
就是等于是第一个把。
这种深层式网络来做这种。
NVIDIA深层把他带起来。
那做了一段时间之后。
公司就觉得我可以了。
然后就可以开始成立自己的团队。
那我那时候成立的团队。
就叫The Imagination Research。
跟我当初给drop talk的目标是一致。
这是哪一年
19到20年之间。
那时候变成一个research director。
但就是
那时候知道自己要成立团队。
就跟着几个一起工作的伙伴。
就开始建立Deep Imagination Research。
那接Deep Imagination Research之后。
就一直
就是在解相关的问题。
就一步一步想从这个。
就是朝着
把小说放进去
产生定义这个目标前进。
就是
一步一步往下走
我们做了几个
有趣的这种demo。
就是有一年
Jensen
我们的CEO
他想要
用一个数字人来取代他。
来给这个keynote。
那时候我们就帮他做这个。
假的Jensen这个。
Keynote的demo。
然后还有陆陆续续。
那时候是疫情期间。
然后在暖时间里面。
数字人的发展非常的快。
然后我们也供了一些。
我们自己觉得很骄傲的technology。
我十年前在给Job Talk的时候。
我就想要解这个小说。
变成电影这个题目。
但那时候
我觉得
这个题目可能需要很久的时间才能解。
应该是说
我那时候并没有意识到。
我们其实有
已经有这个条件了。
当你的算力
当你的数据足够的时候。
就可以做出这样的一个大的突破。
那但是那时候我就忙着做数字人。
忙着做各种有趣的应用。
到会某一天
open eyes出了这个大理这个work。
最早的一个test image model。
我才理解到我的野心不够大。
我不够勇敢
没有决心去把这东西做出来。
在算力最多的地方。
那时候
NVIDIA是这样运作的。
你要捐赦
投资你算力
你要讲出来
这为什么对公子重要。
我记得那时候
达利出来的时候
我写了一封信给捐赦。
跟他讲说
这个未来
已经很明确了
就是靠deep learning来做这个。
影响审承
那NVIDIA
很多客户
都是用NVIDIA GPU。
用传统的graphics。
来做这个影响审承。
那我们不能在这个。
用deep learning来做影响审承下落后。
我们必须投资GPU。
给给我们这个团队。
去帮助这个领域成长。
那那段时间里面
我跟getty images也有很多合作。
因为我一直在做这个方向。
那这些传统的content公司。
他们也对这个AI很感兴趣。
但他们也就是
就是试看看
但没有没有足够多的决心。
那看了达利之后
我写一封信跟选择要GPU。
写了一封信给getty images说。
我们应该合作
你们这样未来才有比较保障。
然后
我们就谈成了这个合作方案。
就是他们提供数据。
然后我们有算力
然后我们去逼这个大模型。
来做这个test image。
这就是我踏入大模型的时间点。
那时候我们成立的一个专案叫。
picasso
我们目标是做AI foundry。
就是有些公司有数据。
但他并没有这种
AI的人才没有这种AI的infrastructure。
但他没有数据
他没有客户
我们就是等于帮他做一个gen AI的模型。
然后再把模型给他们。
让他们去部他们客户。
然后彼此就是这样一起获利。
那时候就是跟getty image。
还有跟shadow star去做这件事情。
那这是
那时候还是在deep imagination research。
这个团队的事情
我们再做这件事情。
那从这里就是慢慢的。
我的research不只是产生一个模型。
不只是产生一个论文。
我们也产生了一个。
可以帮助客户成功的产品。
那就是这样
止步的发展
我当初以为我现在已经决心充足。
然后就是愿意挑战最困难的问题。
因为已经跟捐赠要的GPU。
跟
当时要多少GPU。
那时候我是要了1000个A100GPU。
当时的1000张很多嘛？
那时候是非常的多。
那时候还在ampere的时代。
1000张已经很多。
那要把1000张的GPU。
串在一起做一个高效的训练也不容易。
这次我们那时候尝试就是。
当然遇到很多瓶剪。
就是主义客服
因为我是最早
EP去做GNAI的。
整体在computer vision里面做GNAI的人。
我也很荣幸就是
就是跟很多很优秀的伙伴一起合作。
因为我比较自胜
然后很多当时很有为的年纪人。
还在学生的时代
他们会来我自己做实习。
然后包含现在在Meta的瑜伽会。
做出这个sora的teambooks。
都在我这里实习
我记得teambooks刚加入我团队。
做实习的时候
他就一直想做这个video生成。
想做他想做的sora的东西。
但那时候我们并没有这个technology。
我们是用Gain一起去做合作。
那时候就看到他的充满的决心。
充满的热情
然后当然是人非常的聪明。
然后手脚也非常的快。
那我们在他一起合作里面。
学到很多东西
我们也写了一个蛮不错的论文。
那后来毕业之后想留住他。
但他去了open.io。
也很开心
他在open.io那边就是获得很好的发展。
然后后来就做出这个sora的work。
那sora的work出来之后。
对
对我的
我是感到非常的开心。
但我又觉得
我的决心还是不够。
还是不够
我们那时候就几位。
就是都在做这个领域的人。
我们就一起
和一起写了一本信给全程说。
我们必须要更多的口词。
这就是cosmos project的由来。
我们这一群学者
我那时候还有三压feeder。
然后还有我们公司。
带这个Nimo床团队的。
Buan Canarado。
军犯那时候也在这个meeting里面。
我们就已经讨论
我们就决定要去做这个。
这个war model。
我觉得这对公司
像是对人类像是一个重要的。
一个科技
然后那时候军政就叫我。
还有三压feeder两个习来带。
这个cosmos这个effort。
那时候不叫cosmos。
那时候就是我们知道。
要做warsimulator。
然后
全程就叫我们每个人去想。
要叫什么？
这个project叫什么名字。
我们就每个人就回去去想。
就是要叫什么？
我一定忘记那时候有几个名字。
在那边选
但最后全程就说叫cosmos。
然后我们觉得cosmos这个名字。
非常的好
然后
所以这个cosmos。
这个project是这样的产生的。
然后我这个
还是在dead imagination lab的时期。
那在那个时期就是。
我原本是在做picasso。
然后就是这个AI防处。
for这个media generation。
然后但是同时又负责cosmos。
我后来觉得就是cosmos这个project。
不然是对公司对整个利润范更加重要。
然后也没办法分身法力。
没办法同时跑两个重大的project。
然后慢慢就把这个picasso这个project给收起来。
那帮这些客户找到了其他可以继续。
支援他们的科技公司。
然后就前去开始做cosmos。
那cosmos做一段时间。
从1做到2做到3。
这段时间里面
使用它的客户越来越多。
需要一定的规模
才能去把这个cosmos这个project做好。
你可以想像我在research时期。
可能就是像一个萌芽阶段。
当现在这个cosmos已经被这么多人给依赖。
不管是外面的客户。
或者是公司内部的团队。
到一个不能
就是一定要成功的阶段。
那所需要的资源更加的庞大。
那就是在今年年初的时候。
我就从mediaresearch离开了。
我现在是report给我们的。
Cineal VP of software。
我们公司最大的一个leader。
之前是会包给beautary。
对 带着deep imagination团队。
我现在report给dwight。
就是我们公司的第一个soft engineer。
在健身的专辑里都有他的故事。
对 那我现在report给他。
然后我离开research之后。
我们就换了一个名字。
然后我就不叫自己的团队。
deep imagination research team。
我们就叫自己cosmos lab。
这是整个这样的一个变化。
我听说sora没有出自你的团队。
让你很遗憾是吗？
也不是遗憾
就是我自己感到很开心。
就是自己曾经一起共识过的人。
可以做出这么大的一个贡献。
感到非常的开心
遗憾的是说
每个研究员都想做出贡献。
那看到这个soul啊？
这个产生的贡献这么大。
当然自己会觉得很开心。
一方面也觉得说
到底是什么地方
在我的决策过程当中。
在我的判断的过程当中。
是哪些地方我没有看对。
而导致我没有在正确的时期。
做出正确的事情
一点就是
我是习哥很喜欢自我反省的人。
我就是往往都会去试图理解。
怎么样让自己更好。
因为说到sora还是会想多说一句。
你觉得为什么open。
后来把这条产品线。
基本上算是关掉了。
sora它是一个重大的一个研究工作。
那它当然本身也有许多应用。
openai是一个很有业性的公司。
然后他们有大量的人才。
那sendalman一直是。
从他早期在ycombined。
他就是一个投资者。
那他当然是希望
就是有这种投资者的心态。
然后希望公司内部有各式各样的project。
有些project非常的成功。
就是各式各样的portfolio。
对
那我觉得在过去一年当中。
他们受到这个
anthropic巨大的竞争压力。
他们看到anthropic在coding。
Agent上面产生了巨大的经济效应。
你在跟确计bt聊天的时候。
你产生的token数就是。
可能最多一分钟就生成完了。
那你做这个coding agent。
可以工作24小时。
14-18小时
这个token量非常的大。
那他们就是我觉得。
觉得这是一个很好的方向。
那就集中公司的经历。
往coding的方向走。
孙子兵法讲的
背多着力寡
大家的资源都是有限的。
那他们就是重新调整资源。
然后去往coding这边发展。
我不觉得他们认为。
solar不是一个好的work。
只是我觉得在这个时间点。
他们公司有更重要的事情。
必须要去做
那就要做出一个不容易的决定。
我很好奇啊？
因为像anthropic。
open eye这种前沿实验室。
他们做研究天津第一。
因为这就是他们的产品。
但是对于英伟达这样的一个。
基础设施公司
或者说是一个平台公司。
我卖token给这些前沿实验室就好了。
为什么还要自己做自己的研究呢？
就是研究这件事情。
本身对于英伟达的意义是什么？
你的基础设施要做得好。
做得好的定义就是适合这些。
应用公司来用
那如果你自己不做这些应用。
你更不能理解他们所需要的东西。
所以就是要去走他们。
可能会走的路
从中间去接接到
而且设计晶片
设计这个电脑的架构。
它的周期是很长的。
你不能说我现在马上改。
需要很长的一段时间来做这个规划。
所以你要做这方面的研究。
做他们的投资去接到什么？
可能是重要的问题要解。
但设计出更好的晶片。
更好的infrastructure来满足这些。
就是AI大公司
我总觉得这世界上如果每个想。
有包袱有理想的人都有这个工具。
可以做出他们想做的事情。
这世界是为一个更好的世界。
一方面看到OPPAI & SWAPIC。
还有中国几家大公司做出的突破。
觉得非常开心
但我们这个社会会永远不觉得。
有包袱的年轻人
我们也希望他们有他们的机会。
就是我们可以做出这些模型。
然后分享给他们
他们可以做出很好的应用。
很好的延伸模型
或者从此里面获得灵感。
做出他们更好的模型。
然后就是大家不同的想法都可以落地。
然后我觉得当这么多多元的。
这些idea都就机会被实现。
然后可以被呈现给这些用户。
我觉得大家选择更多。
那我觉得社会进步会更好。
那这方面为什么？
因为大家做开源模型的原因。
嗯
那你们的研究成果会跟客户区。
有一些竞争关系吗？
我们做这些
而且我们做这种开源的模型。
我们基本上就是无价放在。
网络上面
让大家都可以去运用。
这事实上真正要落地。
真正要满足客户的需求。
还很多东西要做
尤其在巨生领域
好多硬体的问题啊？
好多这个商业的问题都必须要解。
我觉得我们给community一个讯号是说。
我们会帮助你
在这方面
那当你看到这个
这一个趋势
看到我们的commitment。
我们从一代做到二代。
做到二点五代做到三代。
这样一代做下去
你看到我们一步一步。
就是想把这个地方做得更好。
让你让这家都可以更加。
预期到说
因为他在上面会一直投资。
一直进步
那大家有这个
认知有这个信心
那他就可以把他的。
就是他资源投在
更重要的刀骨上面。
去做出重大的贡献。
因为
每家公司再有钱的公司。
资源都是有限的
那你不找到痛点
找到这个关键点去做。
投资做进步的话
也是不容易脱颖而出的。
那继承这么的难
这么东西要解
我觉得我们
他做出这些模型
帮助他们分担部分的压力。
我不觉得是在竞争。
我觉得是在帮助大家成功。
对 为什么你们当时。
要立一个非常重要的项目。
没有选择当时最火大原模型。
也没有选择像sora这样的模型。
而是选择了巨绅的一个世界模型。
大原模型
它在当时发展的已经非常好的。
然后再来就是
我的背景不是大原模型。
我是computed vision出生的。
cb出生的
对cb出生的
那
这样而然就是一直在这个media。
这边拍怀
就是image video拍怀。
那
就是大概是过去的背景。
就是把自己走向这个。
导渡上
因为我的背景关系。
所以跟着我一起
合作的伙伴也都是类似的背景。
所以我们就是往这方向走。
这是为什么没有走大原模型。
那另外就是
nbi也有很强大的大原模型团队。
在那里
我觉得我没有太多的贡献。
然后我觉得
Nimo床越做越好。
那我这边就是
主要就是想去解一些。
更适合我来解的问题。
那sora当初出来的时候。
它也是一个wash emulator。
但那时候主要的应用。
比较像是这种创作。
方面的应用
创作非常有趣
每个人都希望
可以用更好的房子来去讲故事。
去呈现自己想的东西。
就是具象化
帮助大家去理解你看到的世界。
这是一个很好的应用。
但那时候也看到的就是。
我们在这种digital AI发展。
极大的
非常的快
同时间设备很多问题。
需要
这些 physical tour。
真正能改变
物理世界状态的
这些 physical tour。
安然满足的
比如说
就是当人年纪大的时候。
就没法开车
但没法开车
整个人的生物品质就降低很多。
但如果有自动车
年纪大人
还是可以有他的 mobility。
再来就是
有很多工作
非常劳力密集的
也非常的危险
如果有这种 physical AI的。
这种roba
可以帮忙做
也可以就是改善人的生活。
然后在家里面总是一堆所事。
要收完快
要整理
这些不见得是你在家里面。
就想做的事情
有机器人可以帮忙去做这件事情。
提升人的生活品质。
我们就是看到
就是one model。
可以对 physical AI。
所产生的贡献
所以那时候就往
这个 physical AI 方向走。
而不是走这种
content creation 的路线。
Jason 对于这个团队。
提过什么要求没有。
Jason 对团队的要求。
非常的严格
然后目标高
当然第一目标就是。
可以帮助到客户
这不是一件容易的事情。
NVIDIA 是一个运算公司。
是一个 AI 音法刷球的公司。
我们最厉害的就是。
整个 computer stack。
从底层音法到裤的。
到一路往上
但是我们并不是
一个 solution 的公司。
就是给一个机器人的 solution。
或者是一些其他应用的 solution。
那但我们的目标是。
帮助这些建 solution 的公司成功。
那有时候会觉得有点像。
隔学烧养
因为你不太了解
痛点在哪里
那你设计模型的时候。
你设计一个产品
如果你不了解你的客户的话。
就没法追加化
那这就是为什么？
我会常来中国原因。
就是想理解一下
大家遇到的问题是什么？
怎么去帮助他们
就是一个难处
一个军生的要求
那做东西是需要 make impact。
军生常常在讲就是。
他喜欢这种 zero billion dollar business。
你可以是不赚钱
但当这个生意成功的时候。
必须是很 influential 的。
是很巨大的
你不能说就是满足在。
就是每年赚个
100 个 million 这种 scale。
这对很多公司的研究很大。
但对一个
对英伟的大家的公司的研究。
这并不是一个 destruction。
是一个分心
分心
对 是个分心
就是你要去解最重要的问题。
产生最大的贡献
那我们觉得 physical 还是一个。
够大的问题可以产生最大的贡献。
所以在这个方向的时候要很小心。
就是要去解最重要的问题。
而不只去解一些
短暂可以产生成果。
但他的 impact 并不是很大。
那这是其中一个问题。
那当然就是
要做最好
那这也是很难的
听起来过去10年的名誉。
在英伟答辩的越来越具有野心了。
是
那接下来我也想探索一下。
就是你个人的一个。
作为研究员的刘茗玉。
你是怎么一步一步。
探索你的研究之路的。
再回答你这个问题。
我先想想回答之前的问题。
我觉得我是一直很有野心的。
因为我那时候就认为。
可以用小说直接生成地。
只是我觉得我的知行力不够。
我的看时间点不够。
然后我不太会去理解。
但那时候还是刚进业界不久。
还不太理解
怎么样做才是
可以在公司中获取知识。
然后获得巨大的资源去从事方向。
那我觉得过去实验历练里面。
那我就跟大家理解。
怎么样看清楚在对的时机。
然后怎么样
就是帮助公司理解。
这是对公司重要的决定。
然后去影响公司怎么去投资。
这是我觉得一个变化。
是一直很有野心
只是不知道怎么实行。
我最早
因为那时候成长北京。
我在台北长大
然后在我读高中的时期。
最热门的科技是无线通讯。
那时候那个手机刚出来。
还是巨大的手机
然后还是Nokia的时代。
那时候对这个科技感到非常的。
就是好奇在台北长大。
那总想离开台北
然后我这时候就去了台湾的。
交通大学在新竹
那边去学习这个无线通讯。
那无线通讯在那边学了一段时间之后。
就比较理解它是怎么做的。
在我的同学
那时候一起在那个。
新竹交通大学秋学。
学无线通讯这些同学。
很多人就留在台湾去。
比如说在联发课
或者是有些人去台积电。
去做这些台湾本身就很善堂的工作。
那我在那时候就有点怀疑。
是不是这就是我要选择的道路。
因为我从小到大
其实没有想过说会去美国留学。
没有想过
所以我其实一直不知很钟识我的英文。
就是觉得数学物理学得好就够。
那时期我就开始有点怀疑。
到底什么路是对的。
在大三那一年
我就好奇去看看美国的研究所。
博士班在说什么东西。
然后我看看我自己。
现在那时候在台湾的交通大学做什么东西。
然后那时候我就发觉就是。
做东西很不一样
然后我觉得
我那时候在算怎么样。
设计一个Protocol。
可以让传输更加快。
那我觉得这是一种提升。
但不是一个0到1的变化。
那我看到在美国这些高等学府做东西。
我就觉得这个看起来。
每个成功都是一个0到1的变化。
所以那时候我就觉得。
我应该出去闯一闯。
然后我跟我才记得我跟我爸妈说。
我要去美国留学的时候。
他们就吓了一跳
因为他们认识我20几年。
没有听过我讲说
我要去美国留学这件事情。
这是大级
大三的时候
然后所以他们听到就是还蛮震惊的。
那时候我想去美国学习的是量子通讯。
因为我觉得这个东西很神奇。
这个套的量子
可以直接把讯息从A传到B去。
但后来我到去美国之前。
我在台湾的英特尔。
在那边待了一年
然后认识了一个朋友。
我们都在那里实习。
他在那里做这个音箱辩识。
然后我就是我第一次接触到AI。
因为之前都是学通信。
然后我看到他在做音箱辩识。
我觉得这很神奇
他就是可以从这些Pixel里面去判断。
里面是什么东西
是谁 是什么物件。
然后我就对这个AI Computery Vision。
开始有些印象
那我那时候申请到了美国马里兰大选。
在那边开始我的博士。
那最早期的Computer Vision都不是Blog。
那最主要的那个经费研究都是国防。
那马里兰的那个华盛顿特区很近。
所以那时候具体有一些非常厉害的。
就是早期的做Computer VisionAI方向的。
大佬在那里
那我到那个学校之后。
原本是要研究这样子通讯的。
然后后来发现那里有做这种Computer Vision。
我那时候在Intel实习看到的东西。
很接近你的这个题目。
我就觉得说
嗯 这看起来更有趣。
然后我就找了我的指导教授Ramachalapa。
他是这个
林云里面等于是先锋。
然后我就开始跟大家学习AI。
Computer Vision。
那说最早做的第一个题目呢？
就是从Video里面去看这个人走路的姿态。
去判断是谁
哇哦
那是那时候也是蛮有趣的问题。
那我就是在这样逐渐逐渐就是。
转换跑道
然后去做这个AI。
然后最早期去做这些影像辨识。
video辨识
然后后来在博士期间还学习。
怎么用叫Shape。
Matching。
然后Segmentation这些。
常见的这个Understanding方向的这个。
AI Computer Vision的研究。
这样逐渐踏进这个AI的。
那那时期
并没有Deep Learning。
是一个传统计算机视觉的事情。
传统计算机视觉
那时候什么都不Work。
所以什么都要学
我们那时候做Support Veteran Machine。
那是一个很传统的用Machine Learning的方式。
Support Veteran Machine跟优化有很大的关系。
然后就是一个不管是连续。
离散的优化都不需要学。
然后也要去学习一些Graphical Model。
Energy Minimization。
然后各式各样的
就是
就是3D Calibration这些东西。
就学的蛮多
我觉得算是很扎实。
但就是在毕业的那一年。
ImagingNet这个AliceNet出来。
然后改变了整个世界。
PHD的后期就到一家叫。
Mizubishi Electric Research Lab。
的一家工资
三年电机研究院
这是你后来的一个工作对吧？
对这是我的第一份工作。
在美国的第一份工作。
对在美国的第一份工作。
它是在
Cambridge。
在Meterchuser。
在MIT的旁边
这家公司在90年代。
是非常强大的一个研究单位。
那时候跟围乱研究院是一帧四雄。
在Graphic上面。
都是非常领先的一个研究机构。
那MIT里面有许多教授。
以前都是在那个
三零电机研究院里面当研究员。
包含Bill Freeman。
Ramash Raskar。
他都在那边做
那我加入的时候已经过那个事情。
但是还是很多优秀的研究员。
就下来
那我记得那个公司之后。
几件事情嘛？
那一年
Alice Net出来。
所以我过去学的东西。
就是跟未来的世界开始有些。
divergence。
那一课会失落吗？
不会
我其实在
我是对这些新的科技一直很感兴趣。
因为computer vision。
因为什么都不work。
所以我已经养成这个习惯什么都学。
什么都不work。
那时候什么都不work。
然后后来Deep Learning。
出来之后
就觉得很有趣
我还记得我那时候是博士班的作业年了嘛？
等于是
实验室里的大师兄。
然后我就组织学弟妹们。
师弟妹们继续去
要研究Deep的年。
就是去研究
那我还记得那时候有一位。
师弟跟我讲说
这东西只有几个人会。
没有必要去研究
然后
我还是没有理他
就是继续班这个研讨会。
然后后来
我的第一份工作是在。
这个三零电机研究院。
研究院通常就是研究风气。
就是工作比较自由。
那我有很多时间去学习。
所以我在那里就学Deep Learning。
Journey Model是我的制造教授。
Roma Chalaba。
他很相信Journey Model。
他相信Bation。
就是相信你要把那个生存放在这个。
这是understanding的一部分。
那所以我在那时候学Deep Learning的时候。
也带留意生存的这一块。
那后来有一年去了Neurus。
看到Ean Goodfellow的。
生存对抗网络的工作。
就对这个东西感到非常有兴趣。
然后就开始
在这方向里面就开始做大量的投资。
然后越学越多
你好像很早就开始做生存了。
对
或是最早做生存的一批研究员。
那时候还在
只要能生成32成32批寿的力眼。
然后看起来不像鬼。
然后就觉得自己很成功。
所以为什么生存是理解的一部分。
Rucha Feynman他讲的。
If I cannot create, I cannot understand。
就是当你可以去生存它。
所以你真正去彻底的理解它。
而这个人的学习有点像。
对
是
当你可以讲的时候。
意味着你已经理解了。
还有早期
就是Computer Vision也分这种。
Discriminative Model跟Gerative Model。
Discriminative Model是。
它其实没有生存能力。
但它可以判断
这是A还是B
判别式
那生存模型就是
一样可以被用来做判别。
但是它还是包含可以去重建讯号。
就是可以去描述它。
然后当你可以描述清楚的时候。
大家是可能认为你更加理解这个东西的。
那就是Discriminative跟Gerative。
所以像最早期的AliceNet。
可以做ImageNet Classification。
我们就把它看成是一个。
判别式网络
其实你最早做了一年的工程师。
你觉得这个经历对你后来做Research有影响吗？
你就是在英特尔做工程师。
对
以及你觉得做Engineering和做Researcher的。
本质的差异是什么？
你又更适合你自己。
这是一个好问题
做Research。
最重要一部分就是问对问题。
问对问题
当你问到对的问题。
你就大概找对一个方向。
那Engineering等于是帮助你去跟大家讲。
对 这是对的问题。
就是要把东西做出来。
因为一个实现能力。
让你去做这件事情。
那Engineering当做大Scale的时候。
还有很多东西是很重要的。
在去美国之前的那一年做Engineering对我影响。
我可能最大影响就是。
认知了有这个领域叫AI。
Competition。
然后从中间
我以前那时候在巨大的Software Stack里面。
帮公司去找问题
那这也是很磨练耐心的一个过程。
那我觉得都是很好的训练。
所以AI对你来说也是一场意外。
它本来不在激进的轨迹之中。
不算
我不是那种从小就是说。
我要去理解为什么人类。
为什么可以有这个智能的发声。
我等于是
就是一步一步看到这东西。
觉得非常有趣
想去理解
然后就一步一步往那边方向前进。
它最初打动你的是什么呢？
为什么打动我吗？
最初
后来当然可以有很多原因了。
因为不懂
对 不懂
那又比较容易去理解它的重要性。
就是有些科技领域像这样子通讯。
你可能要很懂
你才知道它到底是为什么重要。
这个AI就是很容易可以理解。
就是你可以重造这个智力。
那它有些表现会跟人非常的像。
那这就很好奇了
因为还有就是
当然每个人都对自己的。
就是存在会产生这个困惑。
整个群体就是到底什么是人。
我们跟其他生活有什么不同。
那这就是一个很自然你会问的问题。
那我觉得
也是因为这个原因。
这个灵运会吸引这么多人在上面做出口路。
如果要找到一个早期对你研究生涯。
都非常重要的一个时刻。
你会这么描述它
它是哪个时刻
它是你在做工程师的阶段。
还是你到美国之后。
太多了
对 那哪一个是最重要的。
或者最重要的三个呢？
我觉得第一个时刻就是。
在找其我喜欢漂亮的数学。
在computer vision早期阶段。
什么东西都不过
那computer vision。
运用大量的优化的算法。
那优化呢？
就是要去找最佳解。
如果是连续性的呢？
常常我遇到这种non-convex的问题。
就是你没办法找到最佳解。
那如果是离散呢？
就这种nb hard的问题。
就是你也没有足够的算力。
去找到最佳解
你还是研究出算法去找一个答案。
但你不知道答案离最佳解多远。
那为了去确保你的答案离最佳解。
不是太远
就是有一定的就是保证。
然后就去证明这叫bump的。
就也许这个最佳解是。
虽然找答案不最佳解。
但它离最佳解可能就是差10%。
或是差20%
这比随便一个答案好。
为了去证明这个bump的。
很多时候在早期的研究。
就会开始做一些假设。
假设让你的数学变得比较干净。
可以找到答案
但假设也让你离现实比较远。
然后那时候早期会有点偏向于。
去找追求数学的美。
而去忽略了跟真实世界的距离。
然后后来一段时间之后。
我第一点到这不是一个证券。
因为AI本身就是一个应用。
就是质地就是拿来被应用的。
然后我是越来越喜欢接近这个问题的本质。
而不会被这些花巧的数学给迷惑。
然后后来害一个阶段就是。
可能就是从小成长的背景有关。
就是总是专注在把事情做出来。
而不专注在让别人懂你做出什么东西。
然后我开始做英伟达之后。
就是我觉得我做的research不做。
蛮不错的
然后在别人看到这些。
英伟达之前我就把这东西做出来。
但我不太理解怎么去。
不太会去表现
我做出来的东西一般人可以懂。
然后我常常讲做我自己做100分。
但是我的解释只有10分。
所以别人看到只有10分。
那时候我就更加重视。
如何让我做东西
让别人理解它的重要性。
然后让它去理解这个过程。
那这是我觉得可能一个很重要的一个教课。
那但是我早期做Gain的时候。
然后第三个是我后来理解到。
尤其是开始做大模型的时候。
我开始理解到团结合作是非常重要的一件事情。
人跟人的沟通其实是一个高复杂度的问题。
比如说你
我不知道就是叫n square。
假设你有 n 个人。
你跟这些另外 n 个人沟通是 n square。
n square 在那个复杂度来讲。
是一个不好的复杂度。
只是不容易scale。
就是当里很多人的时候。
就是每个都要点对点。
沟通就不容易
比较好的就是这种 n 或者是 linear 或者 sublinear。
我开始知道说要做出一些巨大贡献。
需要大家起团结合作的时候。
必须要把事情讲得非常明确。
让大家都能懂
然后大家目标能一致。
就是自己能把东西做出来。
然后也希望就是大家都能懂。
是在做什么东西
然后可以朝同一个方向前进。
那这地方就还需要很多。
就是帮助大家去理解为什么这个重要。
这次后来我做科研。
尤其是做到大的scale的科研里面觉得很重要的一件事情。
你要做应用
然后你要销售你的工作。
你要团队一些做
对
是
这其实也是你的成长的路线对吧？
当我做出了第一个。
那时候我一个很popular。
我叫高gan
那时候大家都在用他。
就是我刚讲的马良生比。
我看到用户的反馈。
让我充满了就是成就感。
那我觉得说
我能影响的不只是度我paper 的研究员。
而是一些就是更大的一个族群。
然后可能就觉得自己的生命更有夹子。
然后就朝同方向前进。
高gan是取之高更吗？
对
这个名字是这样
那时候我是跟一个。
我那时候的士兮生叫那个Tessan Park。
他我们一直在研究这个方向。
然后当然还有
他有一起合作
还有朱俊烟
然后还有那个王鼎俊。
我们这四个就是一起在研究这个题目。
那
那时候我们开发出一个算法。
叫我们叫十倍的就是adaptive modulation。
demodulation。
这是一个算法
那时候做出来之后。
很开心
我在公司内部做个demo。
然后俊臣看到非常的兴奋。
然后他问我叫什么名字。
我就叫十倍的
就不喜欢
就是这东西就是不容易懂。
不是一个用户语言。
不是用户语言
那时候就是paper 已经写完了。
投了cvpr
但还没有放在archive上面。
然后公司看到之后就叫我不要放在archive上面。
让俊臣在GTC
那是2019年的GTC的时候。
可以在他的大会里面跟大家宣布。
然后我觉得很新奋。
很好的机会
那
那他们就在想这叫什么？
我们公司有一个
market in the genius。
就想说这叫
因为那时候算法都是什么gain。
什么gain
对
就是gain 的时代。
对gain 的时代。
然后那个market。
他就要做那个
greg estates。
然后他就提出
叫高根
高根
他是法国人
就把这个名字取出来。
然后大家听到的名字。
很合理
画家
著名画家
然后那时候做应用也是这个。
画画的这件事情
然后就就出来了
那时候本来是在GTC。
他的就是捐赠大会上面要去宣布的。
结果那一年他太多产品要介绍了。
他最后一刻就
我记得我在礼拜天晚上还跟他在那边排练。
就是要在台上给个demo。
然后当天晚上就接收到通知说。
太多产品要讲了
他决定把这个高根就不放在他的kilo上面。
就一样是做了新闻稿。
一样就多demo给这个媒体朋友去看。
但就没有放在这个他的大会上面。
很多媒体朋友看到他之后。
反而是GTC里面最受矚目的一个work。
然后就那一年就这样的很多种事。
然后我们做一个online app。
让大家都去测试
然后从里面就是大家使用里面。
获得很多就是很好的板规。
然后就就是越做越往应用方向前进。
其实勾干是不是跟你之前的研究轨迹。
是一步一步递进的。
他不是第一天就做到那里了。
因为你从博士毕业以后加入了。
三菱电机研究所
computed vision就进入了GaN的时代。
然后你其实为了GaN做了一系列的工作。
包括kilo GaN。
moco GaN。
暂时到了英伟达之后的。
比如说高GaN这一系列的工作。
对吗？
他是怎么延展的
我最早的一个GaN的工作叫。
那个coupled GaN。
coupled GaN。
coupled GaN就是把两个GaN的。
生成网络把它coupled在一起。
然后coupled在一起产生了一个。
information bottleneck。
然后所有的dimending。
就是在学什么压缩咨询。
然后bottleneck是帮助你。
帮就是给这个newer。
一个机会可以去找到本质。
那就是你一个GaN是在model一个discribution。
然后你有两个GaN是model两个discribution。
一个是码一个是办码。
当你coupled在一起以后他就有一个限制。
就会找一些共同性。
然后就可以让你做这个转换。
从码变办码
那从这个方向走的。
整个生成是网络就是在做这个discribution modeling。
那discribution modeling就是你可以simple。
就产生一个image。
一个山 一个海或一个video。
但是人不只是想要去生成。
他要去能控制自己去生成的东西。
那控制就是要讯号。
那讯号有很多种
那一种常见的讯号就是。
拿image当个讯号。
就是我这有一批码 这会变办码。
对 这是一个讯号。
另外一种方法就是。
none age 就是你数秒。
然后还有一个就是segmentation。
就是想像小画家一样。
什么颜色代保这山 什么颜色代保这水。
这是一个讯号
然后
再来就是
比如说
class 类似说这是山 这是车 这是机车。
那就是生成
然后最
最sophisticated 最接近人的。
nature language 就是text。
就是text to image。
text to video。
这是最
就是最自然的一种形式。
但
它
text 跟
跟这种segmentation最不同一样。
最不同的地方是
segmentation是给你很具体。
这个pixel 是什么？
它帮你对位对好
那text 它是一个。
比较不一样
它的structure 跟image structure。
是很不一样
跟video structure 是很不一样。
因为structure。
很不一样
所以它是
比较难学的
需要更多的数据
所以我发展过程当中。
我是理解到这个问题。
所以我是从比较容易的方向。
一步一步往上走
然后
容易的最早是
这种segmentation。
这种age 或一个image。
那这也是为什么我之前讲说。
dali 让我觉得我自己的。
决心不够
因为我那时候总觉得。
text to image 是很困难的一件问题。
然后觉得
这个领域还没有足够多的。
资讯的data 跟算力来说这件事情。
那其实是有的
然后就是因为没有去做。
所以做不出来
所以你是沿着image。
然后到task的这个路径。
一点一点的延伸的。
对
就其实在早期
我有几个朋友
我们每年一起参加mewreps。
我们就在讨论
我们在讨论说
那时候还没有gbt。
那时候都是早期
我们就在讨论说
如果真正有ai
就是真正会产生突破。
第一个会产生突破的领域是哪一个。
那时候我跟大家讲说。
是text 是language。
是哪一年
应该是1617吧？
我自然自己不说text。
但我知道就是
影像的序号太多杂讯了。
很多东西就是那个。
就是
它离那个知识的本质是比较远的。
它是比较一个就是这个世界的。
就是这个observation。
text 已经是。
已经是很纯净的
比较艰辛symbol。
所以要产生一些
类似智力的表现
最早就是language。
我虽然知道那个
最早的ai会是在language发生。
后来也是真的是这样。
但那时候
我就是比较喜欢这种视觉讯号。
所以就一直留待这个视觉讯号的深圳这边。
后面这几个gand的工作。
你要不要讲一下
那时候就是
imitranslation。
从a 就是那种
马变般
那个风景化
变真实的这个风景。
然后后来又开始做video。
然后我们那时候做一个叫。
叫bit to bit。
那时候是把一个
车子的simulator。
产生那种很简单的这种。
卡通的图片
然后把它变成一个真实的开车场景。
就是
很接近现在的war model。
这些东西
就已经到nvidia了。
对 都到nvidia了。
我只有couple game。
不是在nvidia做的。
剩下的gand都在nvidia做的。
那时候
他们早期做这些工作。
然后
也因为这样子跟ean goodfellow。
就gand的那个发明的人。
成为好朋友
然后我们就
那个就很多讨论
然后也很幸运就是。
在英伟大
就是很多
优秀的研究员
余家辉teamboost。
还有很多
来我这里实习
然后跟他们学习
然后做了很多一些work。
都是围造的
这是imitranslation。
videotranslation。
这方向走
对
然后后来
有一年
我在读phd的时期。
学的都是传统的
这个computer vision的东西。
那phd毕业之后。
deben learnings带来了。
那时候就是想说
你不应该做handcraft的。
arquise and design。
不应该做handcraft的。
feature engineering。
就是应该data举本。
然后那时候也理解到就是。
这种更加scathable的approach。
简单scathableapproach是。
是更容易成功的
所以就常常跟自己讲。
就是说
你在做选择的时候。
要找这种
更加scathable的。
就是后来就大家讲bitter lesson。
那我在做gain的时候很开心。
但我一直在思考
gain到底是不是scathable。
因为gain大家都知道。
说他很难去训练
所以我担心这东西。
就是可能最后不scathable。
那一年余家辉来
我这边试习的时候。
我跟他研究的题目。
就是要去skillgain。
那时候很早
那时候我就看到余家辉。
他的才华洋溢
然后就是做出很多。
就是虽然我们那时候。
没有写出一个paper。
但那时候做的实验量。
非常的惊人
他的想法我看到
哇
还可以这样想
然后就是
比如说那时候
gain是一个generator跟discriminator。
那时候我有幸的是有很大量的gpu。
可以一个cars来swinggain。
他就想到说
每一个gpu都放了一个discriminator。
但是他的weight都不一样。
所以好像很多人
同时跟这个生存室网络做对抗。
在那个时代
能去实现的东西
是很不容易的一件事情。
然后那时候还有另外一个。
实验生
他叫Germain Bustin。
他就是后来发明的一个。
mewang optimizer。
现在大家都在用的mewang optimizer的人。
然后他那时候来我这边实习。
我跟他研究的方向是如何在。
在这种outweizen上面。
更好的算法来去把gain给做的稳定。
但这两个最后
就是方向最后都没有成功。
但他们各自都开发出了。
非常技能的很有成就的工作。
Germain Bustin就是从那时候开始。
我们写了一系列的paper。
就是如何用
mewang早期的算法来去稳定。
来去让这个训练更稳定。
他就是一路一路往下走。
再开发的mewang的算法。
是很开心的一段时光。
学会很多东西
到某一年很努力
然后跟着这么多聪明的人。
在研究这个
怎么让gain更加scalable。
但每个结果都走向。
都是得到一个结论。
就是gain不scalable。
然后我建立这个团队。
就是那时候就是
大家加入原因就是想做gain。
然后那一年我就跟大家讲。
不能做gain了。
要往这个方向不scalable。
我们能够看到diffusion。
觉得这个方法极其稳定。
这应该是17年
不是
应该是2021吧？
就是那时期
17年是transformer发明出来了。
对
17年transformer。
transformer发明出来之后。
我必须讲
我不是早期去接触transformer的。
当时的英文还是LLM。
对
这是LLM那一块。
我一直在专注在gain。
然后早期的gain。
比较好训练的
都是用convolution network。
到占领他把diffusion。
transformer带进来之后才。
做diffusion那边的人。
才慢慢的往这个
transformer这边走。
所以那时候就是
从算法层面来看
就是觉得这个gain不scalable。
然后就跟团队讲说。
就是不scalable东西最后做不远。
然后走diffusion。
然后就开始做diffusion。
然后往下走
对
这是一个重大的转变时期。
那做diffusion一开始是做image。
然后后来做multi-view image。
multi-view image就做变成3D generation。
我们就做了一系列这方面的work。
就是adify系列的adify image generator。
adify3D,adify video。
然后做各式各样用diffusion来做的生成。
我听这个我会想到两个点。
就是你在cv这么漫长探索的过程中。
其实计算范图发生好几次变化。
从传统的然后到了gain。
然后又到了diffusion。
正在每次转变的时候。
做一个研究员在其中。
应该是一个什么样的心态。
我发觉这越变越简单了。
会不会觉得我之前的工作都白做了。
真正常常讲就是suffering。
little greatness。
然后在这么多经历当中。
我觉得我现在越来越能掌握。
这个事情的本质
然后我觉得有点像是。
就像传统的科研一样。
就是把事情
就找到真正找到本质。
找到最简单的方式去描述。
这个世界什么运作。
然后我觉得现在的方法就是。
把事情越变越简单。
然后在cosmo这边。
我们也是从数个模型。
最后变成了现在
cosmo三的一个模型。
也同意了
对 就是
今天理解到
OK 原来这就是事情的本质。
然后每一个方向
我都是花了五到十年在投入。
我觉得未来的决定。
我会深受这些过去的经历影响。
然后我也不能说那是错误的。
那时候不能说那是错误。
就是那时候的条件。
那时候的甩离
那时候的数据
在那时候做那些事情是合理的。
那时候学的东西
对我现在做很多事情理解很有帮助。
还有我发现你好几次提到你的实习生。
在AN的lab里是不是就是通过实习生来。
涌泄一些idea是已经很常见的事情。
怎么看待年轻人
比如说
经济的冒症程度是。
根据钱多块
从一个人的口袋留到另外一个口袋。
研究的冒症程度应该是。
根据idea多块。
从一个人的脑袋留到另外一个人的脑袋去。
你听了我的idea。
你有些想法把它变更好。
我听了你新的idea。
我就不错
但这个地方也更好。
你就一直流动
流动流动
然后就idea越好。
那所以
因为我走向业界条路。
就不是去学校做教授。
那如果你只是在业界。
整天交流都是用你的同事。
idea的diversity就低一点。
那因为大家这边我们找很多实习生。
就是跟这些很有想法。
不同背景人一起合作研究。
然后不想学习
我是我觉得这东西是。
是帮助我成长
就是
也帮助他们成长
一个很重要的一个发展。
你12年加入了30。
就是博士毕业加入了30研究所。
然后16年加入英伟达。
你后面职业的变化是怎么发生的。
你怎么加入英伟达的。
自从开始做deep learning之后。
我很相信算力
在30电机不是一个重视算力的公司。
只是一个它是重视算法。
然后那时候为了能做出研究。
做出好的研究
我就常常跟我那时候的manager。
要求要买GPU
对
然后开会就是说我们需要GPU。
要做这件事情
在那个30电机有一个long term mentor。
他叫Anzo Tuzo。
他是也是一个很有名的研究员。
然后他那时候就决定离职。
加入苹果做自动车。
然后
然后我突然间觉得说。
就是当初把我留在30电机的。
主导原因
没有了
然后我就开始思考说。
我是不是也要换工作。
那很自然而然的换工作。
就是到微股跟这些大公司聊一圈。
那时候大家看到就是Google。
Apple
Amazon
这些Meta这些大公司。
然后后来他们的recorder找到我。
然后我看到NVIDIA。
对
每次我都想要买他们的GPU。
然后我这么缺GPU。
这么想要GPU
那为什么我不加入一个。
就是生产GPU的公司。
所以那时候我之后就决定。
就是加入英伟达
那我那时候父亲不太能理解。
因为英伟达是他们没听过的公司。
那时候没听过的公司。
他说您
苹果不错
谷歌不错
你为什么要加入英伟达。
然后我那时候能说。
因为我觉得GPU是最重要的。
尤其是那时候
我开始做Couple Game的时候。
那是一种Unsupervised Approach。
所以Unsupervised Approach。
代表数据取得比较容易一点。
你不需要标注
那我就觉得
那最重要就是算利跟数据。
那我既然数据不需要标注。
那我就去有算利的地方。
然后一件事情很有趣。
就是我后来发觉
就是我那时候在三零电机的manager。
我每次跟他argueGPU。
只要我吵赢了
他给我一些
那个经费去买GPU。
同时之间他会买NVIDIA的股票。
然后后来他就退休了。
他没有告诉你什么当时。
他后来跟我说了
当时没有告诉你
不然你也可以买了。
是的
我看到你在三零电机的工作的时候。
就已经和NVIDIA的人。
有一些合作了什么？
在一些论文上面
不是
我多半是那时期
就是写的那个paper。
因为学术的论文就是审核。
有时候你不是第一次投就会上。
然后可能是多投了几次后才上。
那在三零做的研究。
可能后来到了英伟达之后。
就继续在上面做一些提升。
然后所以才会一些paper的作者。
同时有三零的作者跟英伟达的作者。
并不是在那时候有合作。
公司跟工之间合作没那么容易。
我以为是之前有一些合作基础。
所以你加入了英伟达。
其实不是的
还是正常的一个求职的过程。
对
就是我那时候并不知道英伟达有一个研究机构。
我那时候觉得主要是买GPU。
然后那时候面试我的几位同仁。
我后来跟他聊之后才知道。
他们真的是在做研究才过去的。
那时候英伟达的研究机构没有什么名气。
多少人啊？
那时候去的时候不到100个人吧？
而且不是纯粹做AI研究。
大部分人都是做graphics。
那时候做style给那一帮人。
那时候也不是在做那个。
也不在做get
他们在做别的东西。
然后我都印象很深刻。
就是在NVIDIA research。
每一年都会有一个叫offsite。
就是把世界各地的NVIDIA research的同学。
飞到加州
在硅谷南边有一个小镇。
Monterey下面的一个小镇。
然后那边就有一个地区。
我们在那边做了两三天的研讨。
然后是我第一次见到Terror Keras。
就是发明style game的人。
还有一个Timo Ila。
Sammuli这几个重要的那个。
game的研究员。
那时候他们都没有做game。
然后我已经做一段时间了。
那我遇到他们的时候。
他就跟我讲说
他要把game的问题给解了。
然后我想说
ok
你可能不知道有多难。
我一张希望他们成功。
但是觉得他们有低估他的难度。
然后后来他们就是真的。
一直投入在做这个style game。
从1啊2啊3啊？
然后就不断的突破。
然后我跟他们合作当中。
学到很多东西
对他们一直在做这种uncondition。
不是这种我做的那种控制性的。
但是他们就是对这个细节的追求。
对这个结果的那个追求。
就是影响我这个这个研究的发展很多。
进入因为打作研究。
有像你预计那样
可以有很多的GPU吗？
对这世界上没有任何一个地方GPU是狗。
然后你总是看到不够的地方。
对那我是很幸运
就是我是最早在英文达里面。
做大模型的那个
就是用大量GPU来做。
这个生存式网络的一个研究员。
那因为我早期帮公司做了一些。
就是bizability很高的work。
那所以公司很多人都认识我。
然后那个老黄也对我蛮有信任的。
所以我就可能有信。
有很多GPU资源可以去做这些研究。
但每次都是看到别人的GPU更多。
那觉得自己总是不够。
怎么在一个像因为打这样的公司。
获得更多的GPU。
你需要学会什么？
你要懂公司要解的问题是什么？
然后你要想办法就是跟公司解释。
为什么你做的东西。
会对公司产生影响。
每个研究员都自由自己的想法。
都想解释事情
研究员某方面来讲都是very high ego。
文人相亲之骨接览。
每个都觉得自己想法比别人好。
但公司的本质跟还是不太一样。
就是公司是为了为股东颇利。
那对捐赠来讲
他是希望可以take care of family。
就是整个公司这么多人一起打拼。
因为大家建出来
他希望可以帮大家照顾好family。
就是公司要赚钱
所以我学到一件事情就是。
就是我深信我做东西对自己很重要。
那这东西会产生改变。
产生感改变会帮助公司。
那我要怎么去把这事情讲清楚。
让这个leadership。
让这些不懂的AI的这些leaders。
就是理解到这东西对公司重要。
就是一个重大的的变化。
这是你刚才分享的三个时刻。
你的第二个时刻
这具体是在哪个项目里发生的转变。
我那时候讲的第二个时刻是。
如果让其他的研究员。
更加理解自己做的东西。
就是最重要的心
我就是一个一直不断的变化过程。
我很难讲是具体在什么时候发生。
但我想讲三菱电机的那个案例。
对我印象很大
因为三菱电机在90年代非常的重要。
因为它是早期这种。
就是没有任何限制的地方来做research。
包含领域里面很多著名的人。
像Biofemes那时候在三菱电机研究院。
然后Biofemes吸引了一堆。
比如说Alucard,Ephra。
就是一些著名的教授。
都在那边实习过
那边就是做出很多重大的research。
所以那时候可以跟未来研究院。
可以一起竞争
但某一时期公司的方向改变。
他们开始怀疑这些。
这种Blue Sky Research。
对公司的印象是什么？
就越来越难去justify。
为什么要去配这些research。
然后就产生了一个很著名的。
现在年轻人
大家都没有结束到的事情。
那时候就开始
就是一堆重要的学者。
在三菱电机学者就陆陆续续被fired了。
离开公司
有些就加入微软
有些加入学校当教授。
MIT
然后有些人去 Disney。
人就陆续续的走
那留下来的一些人。
他们还是做的类似research。
但是比较难跟公司的发展方向相关。
比如说三菱电机
对做相机
做这种工业用的相机很感兴趣。
做机器手臂很感兴趣。
所以你帮别人研究。
就是可以获得
公司的支持继续往下走。
那
那我加入的时候已经是这东西都结束了。
那但是我那时候得到训练就是说。
Boost Guys Rich Church跟公司的兴趣也是可以online的。
然后我又常常看到因为在这业界很久常看到这种周期。
就是
很多公司都会一开始的时候就是给很多自由度。
然后很多很有趣的idea都出来了。
但某段时间后开始紧缩。
然后就是留下来一批跟公司这个兴趣比较相关的人。
那就是你可以看到不管是google啊不管是meta都是有这样一个过程。
那我可能是很有幸的在我的资产的早期我就看到这个过程的发生。
所以我在英伟大的时候我就知道我那时候就就是一直认为就是。
首先我知道我做东西跟这个用deeply来深深影响对公司绝对是盛相关的。
更加花心思绪的解决怎么跟公司的决策层解释为什么我做东西重要。
这个特别重要
因为可能是公司在上星期或者是狂仗期的时候。
他允许你做很多boost guys探索。
但是他只要是下层的阶段他就会收索。
对
他一定要你回答为什么你做这个事情重要你跟我有什么关系。
是
而且去做deep learning非常花钱。
对所以你更加要注重解释为什么这对公司是一个重要的投资。
因为大家也会注意到你的研究其实很多时候的理念就是研究之际产品。
这跟那段行李有很大的关系是不是这后面影响你在英伟大的很多的做的研究和产品。
因为比如说你的高gan你刚提的那个项目就是spade的那个算法。
其实也是做成了一个实时绘图的一个产品。
然后包括后面的也做了视频会议增强AI增强的一个产品。
就是所有的研究都会变成一个产品去发布。
是我是算很运气的。
我是一个随着我年纪来越大我越重视效率的人。
所以我很精准的把自己的research变成了一个产品。
我不能说高gan是个产品。
我还建议事情是一个学习一个重要的学习。
AI单独存在并没办法改变一些。
怎么说
在做AI的时候大家都是追求越来越好的模型。
但你慢慢会发现就是模型的那个就是慢慢搜炼。
大家都差不多
当然我有些人会做一部分的进步。
但你看到就是那个这个月那个and so on比较好。
下个月那个gbt比较好。
然后可能下下个月那个no。
绝本来就追上来了。
然后中国这些强大的公司GOM， Kimi， C的。
阿里本人然后deep sick，然后minimass。
这些公司都不断的在在在做突破。
那慢慢的就是大家的模型能力都会差不多。
然后你能模型能力都差不多的时候。
就会理解到说你纯粹靠模型是不够的。
然后我可能是比较运气比较好。
就是早期就就认为这个模型会搜炼。
然后我一直重视就是不能只靠模型。
要跟公司的其他的ego牺牲接的在一起。
你看绝本来做那么好就是绝本来。
google有一整套的这种google dark。
google search。
没有一整套的平台合在一起。
就是当越多人使用你的模型的时候。
你都要反馈越多
然后越方便
就更容易就是对公司产生贡献。
对公司产生贡献贡献愿意给你更多的投资。
你就会做出更好的模型。
就一路可以把这个长期的这个就是发展。
一路一路做下去
所以那我在早期做ai的时候。
就是跟其他的研究员差不多就是。
研究员PGT学生毕业的方式就是写出。
高词样的论文
什么叫高词样的论文呢？
往往就是你在benchmark的结果比别人好。
就是你就是要一个killer。
把别人的方法给起板。
然后再来就是文人详情嘛？
总觉得自己的比较行。
就是一路往下做
所以很多时候早期做研究的时候。
就讲说比别人好
然后到晚期的时候。
我后来接近的理解就是。
比别人好只是其中一个。
就是证明你的东西有价值的方式。
那另外一个方式就是。
你可以帮助到别人。
让大家都变更好
然后发觉就是我
我现在的想法越来越接近。
就是我做出什么东西。
你可以帮助整个领域变好。
而不是追求的就是我比别人好。
这是一种嗨一个还是一种low一个。
我不知道是嗨一个还是low一个。
我就是有幸的在过去20年当中。
遇到好多聪明人物。
总觉得就是这些让人非常的多。
然后我很多实际症都比我优秀。
然后我也觉得这是非常开心的一件事情。
那我觉得我自己能做出东西来。
可以服务这个社会。
但我也不会觉得说。
我一定是比大家都还要优秀。
然后所以我不是说嗨一个。
也不是说low一个。
我就觉得我是有办法产生贡献。
你刚才其实说到一个你做模型的思路。
就是你觉得模型最终会收敛。
他的能力可能会同志化。
但是我理解那些frontier lab。
他们的认知是说智能现在还没有到底。
智能还要继续高速的提升。
你不认可他们这个观点吗？
就他达智能的skill。
我当然一方面很好奇。
然后我自己也在用这些模型。
我也看到他不断的都在提升。
但是有些人总是会讲说。
接下来会有exponential grow。
如果你不敢爱投资这间公司。
或加入这些公司的话。
你就会miss out the opportunity。
然后我觉得历史上。
看过去历史从来没有这样发生过。
就是一下公司就是掌握所有的科技。
其他的公司都没有办法去追上。
这从来没有在世界上发生过。
然后我不觉得ai会是一个例外。
我觉得大家都很聪明。
人员会流动
总是在a公司做一段时间。
总觉得我自己的才华没有受到肯定。
我可能就跳到b公司去。
那这些弄好
这些东西就自然会在领域里面扩散。
然后我总觉得不会有一个。
公司会比其他公司都做一个。
巨大的超前
我觉得这本身就不是一个。
稳定的社会状态
如果推演一下
如果模型的智能
大家达到了一个差不多的水平。
接下来大家竞争的是什么？
就是整合
跟自己的生态
跟自己的产品的整合。
这是大公司
创业公司呢？
创业公司
创业公司的优势是可以走。
大公司不能走的问题。
比如说
对NVIDIA来讲。
任何生意只要是小于一个B连。
就没有兴趣去做
但那些本身就是有一些。
很值得做的东西
然后有本著名的书叫。
那个
叫什么？
Innovative Dynamics。
这是一个
创业者的重进
对
就是往往这些小公司。
在走向那些
当初不是很被看好的。
这个领域
看到有一些东西
可以慢慢出现起来。
很多公司都是这样起来的。
因为大家也是这样的。
对 因为大家是这样起来的。
所以我觉得还是充满机会。
对 我不觉得一定要做。
你如果现在开一间公司。
要跟
no open eye and so on。
不做一样的事情
很危险
对
你的资金绝对没有他们雄厚。
然后你没有客户
你要怎么去累计
然后他们这么大的资源。
可以把东西做便宜。
然后你不容易衰伤。
所以你要去解一些痛点。
是他们没办法去解的。
不是他们不想解
就是他们没办法去解。
他们不能justify。
为什么要去解这件事情。
所以哪怕是
你要做大模型
这件事情本身
最后你也要找到
你自己独特生态
不管是open eye还是andopic。
我们可以看到
and so on。
他早期是被认为
是入后open eye的。
对
但他是最早相信coding的。
当open eye在做。
分散式投资
把鸡蛋
不放在同个篮子里的时候。
and so on。
是做集中式投资
然后最早去做出
这个coding的东西。
所以他那时候就看到了一些。
那个就是机会
然后他就坚信
就决心把它做出来。
所以我觉得对创业者而言。
应该就是要决心
要去看到一个机会。
然后去看到一个
就是你独特的机会。
运用你的资源
把事情做成
但是今天
不管是归国还是中国。
大家又开始
全部同志化的都在做。
coding
你怎么看这个现象。
你觉得这是对的吗？
每个公司做这件事情。
背后都有不同的目的。
好 那我
我不是站在他们的立场。
我无法去讲
但从我角度来看就是。
这其实是很辛苦的一件事情。
对
你说的是同志化竞争。
同志化竞争是很辛苦的一件事情。
我觉得他们
做这件事情可能是被迫的。
因为这是本身是一个。
重要的一个technology。
这可能都不希望自己。
核心科技是被掌握在。
别人的手里
对吧？
但我不觉得
这个是他们计划的全部。
他们一定有其他的计划。
去做出一些差异化。
你没有差异化
就没办法做出
有差别性的产品
最终还是要差异化。
我觉得是
刚才我们其实回溯了。
你的很长的一段经历。
你觉得你作为
刚到美国时候的
第一份工作的研究员。
刘茗玉
然后到后来变成了一个。
在英伟达变成了一个。
tacklade。
然后到现在是一个VP。
研究的VP
你觉得你在不同时期。
解的题是一样的吗？
skill是越来越大。
这个时候就指的
不只是管理的skill对吧？
对
不只是管理的skill。
不管是运算人员的skill。
然后
这跟整个AI发展也有关系。
AI从探索到可以落地。
那就是一个变化
然后这些不同的时期。
都有不同的经历
有时候还是会怀念。
以前那些各种方式。
各东西都不work。
整体就想什么东西。
会work的时光。
为什么？
有多种可能性的时候。
也蛮开心的
就是多个选择
多选择会给你一种开心的方式。
现在的状态就是
也有很多选择
只是就是
我觉得越来越缺进。
我自己蛮喜欢就是。
回到事情的最核心。
然后现在发现
就是很像是
现在的解法都是
重见无风打巧不公。
就是很扎实的
一步一步把这个
Beta 音法做好。
然后就把东西写出来。
在这个知性过程当中。
我也觉得是一个很不错的历练。
从里面学到很多东西。
怎么让这个
帮助团队看到最核心的本质。
然后去提升这个知心力。
但同时间又在
可以创新的地方
让团队做出重大的传扬心。
来去跟上这个时代的边前。
我说各同时期
有不同的挑战
都很有趣
从一个研究员到
英伟达的VP
这个多见吗？
我可能是第一个吧？
你是第一个
你觉得为什么呢？
这是我想问你的
我在英伟达
前几年是每一年跳一集。
然后就一直跳跳跳跳。
就到VP了
对
然后我觉得是因为。
我
早期在NVIDIA。
还没有AI人才的时候。
我觉得在那里
就是帮助公司
然后提升
不管是AI
research的知名度。
或者是解释AI
怎么影响公司
然后我
自己又很喜欢落地。
就是一步一步
就是获得公司的信任。
公司就愿意把这个。
越来越大规模的
的抓案给我做
像现在
想想看就是整个团队。
这么多人
运用这么多运算资源。
每天都是
几百万美金
就是
运算成本啊？
数损成本
我觉得就是纪念
内阅
就是公司有一定的信任。
才有这个机会去带这么大的。
project
所以你跟公司
align非常重要对吧？
对
一个纯粹的
研究员的天性
和一个管理者可能是。
有某种程度上是相背的。
对
研究员要创新
研究员
害一狗
研究员需要
recognition。
然后recognition。
有时候recognition。
跟公司要recognition。
可能不太一样
嗯
那你在成为管理者的道路上。
有没有可能就是
意志一部分
研究员的天性呢？
有没有可能是在
带着料靠跳舞
我觉得我还是个研究员。
我还是常常读论文。
然后我有时候会做些实现。
然后去理解我
我最担心在成为
这个一路成为管理者的。
历程当中
我最担心的一件事情就是。
我跟底层脱购
我不理解
就是问题的核心所在。
然后我会强迫自己。
就是review。
大家的code
然后去读paper。
然后去challenge。
每个人的idea。
然后跟大家做一些。
就是等于就是debate。
来确保这个方向是对的。
我很
跟我公司人来都知道。
我可能是少数
还继续在看扣的vp。
然后还是继续会继续修细节。
我觉得我如果不这样做。
当然我知道我的任务不是一个。
不是成为一个
可能去实现的人
但我是觉得
我如果不做这些东西的话。
我自己会不理解痛点在哪里。
我将就不能去理解。
大家每个人对这个。
专案的贡献在哪里。
就是我只是希望自己一直。
stay grounded。
看清楚一切
然后这样可以
帮助团队成长
然后也可以看清楚。
谁对谁
谁的贡献在哪里
如果说过去20年。
就是你到了美国之后的这20年。
对你影响很大的几个人。
你会说谁
那第一个就是我的制造教授。
Roma Chalapa。
他要帮我担心这个。
debate你这样。
他非常厉害就是
然后他也是非常善于沟通。
然后他可以让任何场面。
都是充满的幻想
其实是
这种很严肃的review meeting。
然后他对人都非常的尊重。
然后就是在他那边学到。
很多东西
然后再来就是
我在我十几三的
我做实习的
第一个mentor on-site do-self。
他就是
手把手教会我
很多这个machine learning的东西。
他对我影响非常
非常大
到英伟达之后
就是多半跟这个
同彩学习
terrocarous。
就是那个style game的一作。
我会受到他的影响非常大。
是哪方面影响
他对东西追求到机制。
你如果读过他的论文。
你看他做的实验分析。
去把这个本子套出来。
这个过程这个
这个坚持
我跟很多不同的研究员。
合作在那个时期
然后那时期
很多研究员就是
一个想法写一篇paper。
同时间
一个系域表可以写20篇paper。
或是40
一年可以写个40篇paper。
terro就是
每年之下写一篇paper。
那就是把他所有的。
他也工作会非常努力。
然后就是把他所有的。
人生的经历
就投注在
同一个idea
越专越细
然后问题的本质
然后产生重打的贡献。
需要牙墙更大
就是这个state focus这件事情。
我可能是从这里面。
跟这些人
共识当中学到很多东西。
那老黄呢？
他对你有影响吗？
非常大的影响
他这个工作非常认真的人。
我在早期加入英伟达的时候。
他常常会传论文叫我看。
传论文
对叫我看
然后我就要写一些summary给他。
跟他帮他讲是什么事情。
他是一个非常热爱学习。
一直去学习
一直去理解
他当初也不懂computer graphics。
他敢踏入做GPU。
他去把computer graphics学起来。
他也不懂deep learning。
也踏进AI直动 deep learning。
对然后就是他强大的学习能力。
强大的兴趣
一直往下走
嗯
他都懂他为什么敢透露呢？
他有一套自己的那个决策法则。
他就是叫first principle。
他就是他会把事情的本质。
把他理性清楚
不会受到外界的讯号的干扰。
他就是看得很清楚。
就是说这方向最make sense。
然后就往那边走
他在早期就敢all in deep learning。
当公司获得巨大的铃鞋。
在早期就敢all in CUDA。
让公司产生了这个很好的foundation。
我在认识尖层之前。
我觉得我的决策就是。
都是偏比较短期的。
然后我看到他怎么去做这种。
长期的决策
然后坚持
然后我觉得是影响非常的惊人。
那他还有一些很惊人的地方。
他的每天的信都非常的多。
邮件是吗？
对 邮件都非常的多。
但他都是很仔细的去读。
然后去找一些别人看不到的讯号。
然后做出一些重大的决定。
而且他是一个很理性的人。
当你事情很多的时候。
你如果没办法去做paradization。
就是把重要事情去做的话。
就是你把时间
你把时间放在不重要的事情上面。
你就不会变成做出重要的事情。
所以你决定哪些事情很重要。
是很重要的一件事情。
paradation。
然后我自己是这样推想的。
他强迫自己每天读大量的email。
强迫自己快速的做决定。
什么是重要的
什么是不重要的
在每天不断的练习之下。
看的事情看得非常清楚。
当你看清楚事情
什么是重要 什么是不重要的时候。
接下来都是执行
读人执行的时候
会把自己的个人情感放在里面。
就说这不重要
但是我跟那个人不错。
然后我是不是应该让他去做。
他不会这样做
他就是觉得说
我做的目标就是take care整个公司。
我只要一直做对公司最重要的决定。
你只要留在公司里面。
我就会take care of you。
对
然后就从里面去学习他。
怎么去做paradation。
然后我觉得这件事情。
我印象非常的大
就是我现在
当research的一年的时候。
可能同时处理两三个paradge。
我觉得好累
每天要换两三个topic。
我现在几乎就是
每半个小时换一个topic。
然后我觉得
以前是没办法想要做这件事情。
但是在这种不断的。
一直做contact switch的状态里面。
也帮助我去更加的理解。
什么东西是比较重要。
对
然后这是很重要的一件事情。
然后黑件事情就是。
如果你学过computer science。
computer science最重要的一件事情就是。
蓝度
就是不用算的东西不要算。
可以完点算的东西。
完点算
可以直接
就是一个no
我就全部一个no。
那你人生就是这么多时间。
你经历了这么多
如果你知道什么东西不要算。
就把它溢出的话
你的人生运用就更有效率。
所以我觉得
还是很值得去学习computer science。
不要因为AI
就不去做computer science。
老黄又把什么？
排入了他的计算范围之外。
每个时期不一样
每个时间连不一样。
这不是永远固定的。
比如说现在呢？
他要处理的事情实在是太多。
也很难说
现在什么东西不是重要。
我自己看到的东西跟他看的东西。
完全不同的等级
他看到的是
他本来是全球AI。
重要的一个推手
对吧？
他看到东西远超过我看的东西。
那我不好评论他
觉得现在什么东西。
觉得不重要
你是怎么保持自己的经历的。
你有什么一些技巧啊？
我是很喜欢运动的人。
我以前喜欢做这种。
团体运动
打篮球啊？
打网球
那我后来就是
我还有一个很大的兴趣就是。
我是一个
投入中国功夫
很多年好几个十年。
就是从十八岁开始。
就一直在练习中国功夫的人。
对我听说你练功夫是吧？
对
有功夫老师
我的武术老师是徐济。
他是一个很有名的武术老师。
他的老师是刘云桥。
刘云桥老师是李淑文。
当初是那个
神枪李淑文
是昌州的武术家的代表。
他的八级拳屁卦长。
对整个
只是整个武术
是一个重大的攻击。
除了整理出来的八级拳屁卦长。
我真的很有趣
就是在台湾
那时候因为
讲切实的关系
有一群武术家
到了台湾
我的老师徐济在那边。
跟刘云桥学
我跟徐济学
才学会这些生物武术。
武术
就是一个很好的
身体的锻炼
不管是心智
然后磨练
体力
对心智磨练都很好。
武术的好处就是
他只要一个人
就可以做运动
然后我早上起来
就是做武术的锻炼。
自己在那边做训练。
蹲蹲装
打打拳
然后我最近还有一个。
新的嗜好就是叫Ice Punch。
就是你用一个冰桶。
然后把像运动员一样。
做完激烈运动之后。
跳进一个冰冷的水池里面。
然后就是帮助身体的修复。
然后我觉得这东西。
也帮助我保持的劲力。
可以面对每天
高强度的挑战
这都是你上班之前。
要做的事情
对
和我对你的印象
还蛮不一样的
因为我每次看你都是一个。
非常谦和的人
但是你还是做一些。
相对有一点点激烈的运动。
对吧？
冰水
武术
我学武术的目标
不是为了打架
是一开始是受到
金融小说的影响
然后那就是对这些。
中国武术充满了兴趣。
学了之后
发现是对自身的一种磨练。
中国武术最重要就是。
控制全身
控制自己
因为你要
发挥
要打出一拳的时候。
最大的力量会来自。
你全身协调
可以把力量
从脚一度关到的手。
这么长的路径
你要控制到全身协调。
这个力量传导是
一步一步到位是很难的。
因为一瞬间发生
所以你要进入不断的练习。
不断的自我修改
我觉得这个跟我
喜欢一直自我检讨。
一直追求
都有很深的影响
我并不是为了展现。
我强大的破坏能力。
我是
我觉得后来变成一种。
对自己的追求
你的性格这种比较温和。
能算温和吗？
你的公司应该不这样吧？
当然不是这样
做久之后都有点
恨蝶不成纲
然后看到
年轻的研究员
就是差那么一点火候。
就可以把事情做更好。
就会忍不住就会
提出来
所以还是会凶的
对吧 在公司里面。
我觉得是一种
是一种
只出这些问题所在。
取决于听的人
听的人
如果是觉得我是正面的。
他就会很开心
因为
这世界上不是
每个人都愿意
跟你讲出
什么地方可以
做进一步的提升
对
然后他们会感激我。
跟他讲说
这个地方
你可以做得更好
但如果你
听者是觉得说
我就在挑剔的话
你就会觉得我很凶。
你这个希望能够一击之胜。
的课题
是不是cosmos。
就是我们整个
组织一个project。
就是cosmos。
对
然后我是非常专注。
在做cosmos。
我会
就是
就是我们就是希望。
透过cosmos。
来对这个世界
产生巨大的贡献
这也是你接下来
也许长达10年
最重要的一个课题吗？
是的
我们做完cosmos。
e的时候
问那个卷层
要不要继续往下做。
然后卷层跟我说
你就做到cosmos 97。
对
我现在做到3而已。
所以还有
还有
还有这个94代
可以往下走
为什么不是100是97。
没有
他是水口说说的
就是
他数字是水口说说。
但他的决心是展现在。
他的这个数字上面。
他是认为这是一个。
重要的方向
然后
希望我们可以继续。
专注
去做这个
物理ai的Foundation。
来帮助整个领域
往下走
我们接下来
重点来聊聊cosmos。
和世界模型吧？
也是你当下最重要的。
一个议题
我看你在你的
个人主页上说
你一直被这样的一个。
愿景所驱动
就是为机器人
构建一个黑客帝国。
对
你们尝试一下这个愿景。
我认为世界模型
可以帮助这些
俱深智能
有
来做到这个
泛化的效果
嗯
那我觉得
任何ai的问题
要解的问题
就是这个泛化的问题。
你能不能在
你看过的训练数据之外。
也能表现得非常好。
泛化
对不对
就是在这个
coding
在这个chat
里面都是
去解
去
训练模型
让它可以去解
在它训练没看到的。
问题
很
很就是
变得像人一样
对吧？
那物理世界的ai。
也不例外
就是要解泛化的问题。
那解泛化的问题
在cosmos
我们是想
这样帮忙
三个点
第一个
提供更好的数据
第二个
是提供更好的起司点。
然后第三个
是提供更好的环境。
嗯
数据是
你可以用生存数据。
帮助ai模型
更加泛化的关键
就是你可以想象
这个世界上
你看到的数据
就是这么多的点
你可不可以去生存一些。
你需要看到的
但是你
生殖世界
你没有采集到的数据。
我把它叫
betadata。
那再就是
如果你可以
训练出一个
好的世界模型
这个世界模型
理解世界怎么运作。
可以去预测
未来发
会发生什么事情
这样的一个模型
它本身的
这个representation。
是不错的
其实是可以提供一个。
物理世界ai
就不管是
parasite model。
还是什么model。
有更好的一个
backbone。
从里面
可以去
就是衍生出
你想要做的parasite。
那这是
更好的起司点
更好的数据
那第三个
人是怎么学习
在这个
物理世界学习
就进有实验
进有
跟这个环境做交互。
跟真实环境做交互。
往往是比较
昂贵的
然后你能
获得的经验
累计的实验是短暂的。
就是一个机械
如果说
你可以用这种
像黑锅帝国
这种去生的方式
可以同时产生多个环境。
真实无比的环境
你可以跟它交互
然后给你讯号
你是可以学习的
非常快的
那就是更好的环境。
更好的数据
更好的起司点
更好的环境
那里面
最具有挑战性的
就是更好的环境
我们不想在
我的网页里面
把它写得非常的长。
像一个essay一样。
就提出了
像黑锅帝国这样
是一个
比较好的一个
就是帮大家
就是理解我们想这么做。
怎么帮助这个
physical eye的community。
Cosmos这个在内部。
具体是怎么立向的。
这是24年
还是25年
24年吧？
24年才是做的
大概24年
3月份左右
我们决定要做
就是在solar之后。
对 在solar之后。
就是完全是那个时间点。
然后大家都在想说。
这个是充满了决心。
一定要做
然后很荣幸的
真正就是信任我
那我去带这个project。
说服它的过程难吗？
在这件事情上
那时候已经不难了。
之前要说服比较难。
大家看到solar之后。
就不难了
它是很聪明的人
他一看就知道
这个东西对
对那个
这东西对公司的影响。
而且它是一个
很有几率的人
有些东西
其实很重要
它会叫你Pace。
Pace your steps。
就是让你不要急
它擅长打马拉松战。
对
所以它是很有几率。
就是
就是慢慢的
一步一步往目标前进。
为什么之前
这个时机还没到
在solar之前。
就是
first mover有first mover的vendage。
对不对
然后每家公司
有不同的定位
对吧？
取决于你想要解决。
什么样的问题
要怎么样活力
我没有足够多的资讯。
来判断
但我不觉得
你看
像现在很多家公司。
都做得很好
现在做video生辰。
最赚钱的
应该是字节
C dance对吧？
所以
这个轨迹是很难说的。
嗯
到solar的时候。
觉得时机到了
对
是你又跟他写了
一封邮件吗？
所以我们这一群
在做这个
生辰式模型的
做这种media generation的。
这群人
一起决定跟真正写邮件。
我猜每个人都会写吧？
对
我们就
每个人都会写
不是一起写一封
我们会讨论
然后一起写一封
然后让大家都会加一件。
然后就是
就变成一个公司的公司。
就是我们必须要
把这东西做出来
哦
这次很回复这份邮件了吗？
对
就是把我们聚集在一起开会嘛？
哦
然后在那个会议上。
打成了一个共识
对
其实会议之前
大家都打成共识了。
嗯
然后那个会议只是。
是更具象化
到底要怎么做
然后谁负责这样子。
你最近会有什么？
记忆深刻的事情吗？
什么场景吗？
就是他叫我们去想名字嘛？
然后我那时候
其实已经知道
最后他会提出更好的名字。
有点拒绝
不想浪费我的力气。
想个名字之后
他想出更好的名字。
但我还猜
我就跟他讲说
你就直接跟我们讲吧？
你觉得什么名字好。
他说不行
你要去思考
去想
我觉得有道理啊？
因为这个名字
跟产品的定位
会非常的相关
嗯
你看我们叫Cosmos。
是一个就是
语作
我们目标
就不是产生这个
content
不是为了要做创作。
就是为了要
解物理世界的问题。
嗯
才慢慢往物理AI。
这面前进
因为sora
其实是一个服务创作者。
的一个事
他早期的demo。
是这样讲
为什么你们当时
选择就是physical AI呢？
就是面向的这个市场。
那时候已经
陆陆续续给看出来。
就是那个
physical AI。
它会是下一个revolution。
因为
这个是个钢区嘛？
嗯
每个人都会老花
每个地方都去把劳动力。
每个人都想提升
更好的生活品质
还一方面来讲就是。
NVIDIA是走这个。
developer market。
嗯
就是
帮助这些开发者
就是做出更好的产品。
我们自己
不会经营一个
社群完善
也不会去建议一个。
创作工具
这有点太2C了
对于NVIDIA来说。
对
所以你们订了
我要做一个世界模型。
然后这个世界模型是。
为了physical AI的。
为服务physical AI的community。
嗯
今天大家对于
世界模型的定义
还是非常不清晰
你跟我们讲讲
你的世界模型的定义吧？
我是个
很讲究使用性的人嘛？
那
人为什么会去
设计一个模型呢？
嗯
就是
它可以用
那用法有很多种
对
比如说
你设计一个模型
设计一个模型来
描述这个世界
经由这个模型
你可以去预测
接下来发生什么事情。
所以它的目的呢？
是为了预测
对
这是一种世界模型的。
为什么去
设计世界模型的
原因
嗯
用处
预测
那另外一种是
你想去理解
为什么这事情发生了。
你模方面来讲
整个物理学
就是
去建世界模型
去了解这个世界
是怎么运作
从这个
牛顿力学
一度到这个
量子力学
就是去
去了解这个世界
是怎么运作
建一个模型嘛？
然后去帮助
我们理解怎么运作。
那当然
从Depenene里面。
我们把
这个
这个understanding。
就是
经有一些
标出的数据
去教这个模型
这个东西会这样
是因为发生这件事情。
然后
经有大量的数据
这样的话
然后
帮助
未来
新的事件
发生的时候
你经有这个
看到的视讯讯号
然后去解释
帮助人去理解
发生什么事情
比如说
这工厂
在工厂里面
为什么这个地方
突然间产现卡住了。
然后可能是
之前某个工人
忘记把什么东西打开。
也是一个
这个世界模型
建了
也是一个目的性
就是为了去
理解发生什么事情。
找到问题
对
还有另外一种世界模型。
就是为了要去
一个世界
有很大的用处
你可以去规划
你东西
路线要怎么走
然后你可以
就是让人去体验一下。
你人
虽然生不在
这个真实世界
但你可以在虚拟的。
状态下
而去在这世界里面。
做游历
就是模型
for the world。
来
然后
因为你的用处不同。
所以它的
模型的形态
长得不一样
终究
我们是在同一个世界里面。
这些模型
就是不同的
经由不同的观察
来去描述
同一件事情
那种重建是
重建是一个
很重要的学问
那我自己本身
就是以前做过重建。
但我现在已经
不再再做重建了
我现在就是
主要是做
物理世界的理解
跟物理世界的生存。
对
就是prediction。
这些事情
大家都会对世界模型。
有不同的解释
现在
定义什么叫war model。
在几年前
同一件事情发生
就是大家定义
什么叫AGI
对不对
然后经过这么多年。
还是没有一个
共同的定义
对
然后我认为
去定义war model。
很可能会走
像同样的道路
我觉得没有
可能不是很重要的。
一件事情
这是因为
这个词太大了吗？
贵龙筒
对
是贵龙筒
那就是
定义出来后
对这人
有什么影响
那为什么？
LLM
就是一个相对
精确的词
LM就是
large language model。
它模型很大
然后做language。
对
就这个词
为什么大家都是
一个有共识的
一个精确的定义
但是世界模型
大家一直在争论不朽。
对
LM就是
LM large language model。
language model。
可以predict。
接下来
会发生什么词汇
对吧？
large代表说。
它的模型很大
对
很明确
对吧？
就是世界模型
就是
一个可以帮助你
去model
这个世界的
一个工具
你要做什么用途呢？
因为用途不同
所以你model的世界。
方式不一样
所以
当只要你对
这个世界
这个模型
有不同的用途之后。
就有不同的定义
所以
你觉得世界模型
能够描述cosmos吗？
还是应该用
另外一个词来描述。
你在做的事情
是
我们
一开始的时候
我们是把cosmo。
叫做
那个
war foundation model。
我们的目标是
建立一个
反射
让大家都可以
建出
适合他们要用的
世界模型
所以我们
把自己叫
Foundation model。
是因为我们希望
我们是一个
更底层
更底层的东西
来满足大家
所以我
所以我是这样
我是这样
我们是这样定义的。
就哪怕
它是一个
要做世界模型的人。
它也可以
基于你的
Foundation model。
是
你是希望提供
那个基座
是的
我们要提供
这个基座
对 就是
一个很重要的
一个环节
但不是
每一个
想从事
Fysical AI的公司。
都有足够多的资源。
去做自己
要的世界模型
从零开始做
但他们又需要
为了帮助他们
我们就做这个
cosmos
这个war foundation model。
因为你们也
同时投资了
Kun的
AMI labs。
和
菲菲老师的
world labs。
你们做的世界模型。
有差异吗？
就是
Media是站在一个。
过的角度
我们希望就是
反正在我们的
GPU
Ecosys上
建立的公司
我们都希望
帮助他们成功
我们希望大家
可以一起走向成功。
win win
然后
每个公司
看到的点
都不太一样
想解的问题
也不一样
所以会有
各式各样的
菲菲的world lab。
杨雷坤的
这个MI
都是不一样
走不一样的路线
那
我们都帮助他们
然后也希望
成功
我们能投资他们
我们跟他们
也有合作
那
如果说
他们对我们的
cosmo东西
有兴趣
他们可以利用
那
其他家公司
他们需要
world model。
但他们可能
没办法
不像菲菲
或是
杨雷坤
资金雄厚
对
他们可能更需要
帮助他们
可以leavage。
我们的cosmo。
我们的目标是
帮助整个领域
成功
所以你没有
竞争对手吗？
我觉得
NVIDIA竞争对手。
跟NVIDIA
做同样的
事情的公司
就是去做
整套AI的
Ecosystem。
那
你说没有竞争对手。
那有些公司
也做出算力
我在做cosmo的时候。
我是不想竞争对手的。
我想的就是
怎么去帮助
这个Ecosystem。
在我的Ecosystem里面。
在NVIDIA的Ecosystem里面。
这些
用我们GPU
用我们运算平台
用软体的公司
他们如果有成功的话。
那
NVIDIA就会。
成功
对吧？
因为他们
所以
一些
还没在我们Ecosystem。
会产生信心
那我觉得
这是帮助的方式
我不太想竞争了
我已经
过那个时期
就是
为了要毕业
把论文发出去
所以我的算法
要比别人好
我现在目标就是
要帮助这个领域
可以一起往下走
因为从第一代
到第三代的cosmo。
其实也经历了
很多的变化
是
你们在第一代
到第二代的过程中。
有没有什么？
解离什么弄好
是的
就是
去年的工作
对
这个步调很快
那时候
开始做那个cosmo的时候。
我强调一个点
就是我们要
迭代快速
那时候
深受DeepSick的影响。
因为
DeepSick是很惊人的公司。
它可以一年内
迭代三次
产生DeepSick V3。
对
所以我强调
就是我们的迭代速度快。
迭代速度快
给一直不断的进步。
一代比一代好
但是我们那时候
挑战的题目是
物理事件模型
然后在那时候
其实20年
不是很清楚
大家都还在没说
怎么样的事件模型。
对大家有帮助
那
我刚才讲的
不外就是
用事件模型是
怎么用它
Prediction。
或understanding。
那就是做这个
这种
video model。
来帮助Predict Future。
然后我是做这种
Ryzenin model。
来解释发生什么事情。
嗯
所以就是
一开始的时候
就是跟一些伙伴合作。
去理解他们的需求。
然后
然后自己本身
有一些想法
然后就做这些模型。
然后跟这些伙伴
迭代之后
才慢慢收敛
就是在过程当中
就是慢慢的收敛冲。
然后我们那时候
做了Predict之后。
可以预测未来
然后想说
嗯
访真环境
是大家常用的环境。
但它的生存的这个video。
就是跟这个
真实世界的训练
一定有差距
可不可以就是
用这个
模型来帮助它
跟
避震
那就做Transfer。
那我解释发生什么事情。
就做了reason。
当日三个
对
然后后来理解到说。
我如果可以去
描述这个
这个Pixel是被这个Pixel。
是怎么变化的
那我这个Pixel变化。
跟我这个Action的变化。
其实很接近的
所以我们就做一个。
叫Cosmoparsie。
给一个Parsie model。
然后后来
陆续续的发觉就是。
就像刚刚讲的一样。
这是同一个世界
不管你从哪就好
路来看你model。
是同一个世界
你模型就是在学一个。
Internal Representation of the world。
就是这个世界
你在做压缩过程当中。
学到怎么样的一个。
表示方式
那既然是同一个东西。
那
还有一个东西就是。
Foundation Model。
它的核心概念就是。
一个可以纳摆穿
就是可以
从各式各样的数据里面。
去学会
就是这个
模式的一个模型
所以如果你可以把。
你穿recent用的data。
穿prede用data。
穿sper用data。
穿parsie用data。
全部合在一起的话。
你是模型的上线更高。
第一个你是描述同一个世界。
然后第二个Foundation Model就是。
就是纳摆穿
把东西合在一起
好
所以就慢慢的
往这个单一模型走。
中间还有一个是
一种直性上的问题。
我记得我刚出
去见了这个
第一版的Cosmo的时候。
我自己算一算
就是因为我是希望。
真的模型可以帮助到。
其他人
然后跟这些partner的合作力。
我可能需要这个模型ABCDEFG。
我自己算一算
那时候可能需要22个模型。
然后那时候我就
有一个会议
跟捐账一起开会
我就跟捐账讲说
我预计需要22个模型。
然后捐账听到
就觉得我工作非常认真。
他就讲
说very good。
no very hard。
然后他讲说
但是你知道吗？
Louis Vuitton LV。
这家店
当他减少他的货品。
成贵
成列的这个货品数之后。
反而sell是提升的。
你不希望太多的东西。
困惑你的
那个消费者
消费者
让他没办法做出决定。
那个对我印象很大。
就是我理解到说
嗯对
我也自己也遇到问题。
因为我自己都分不清楚。
要用A还是用B的。
那其他人更加不清楚。
然后再就是
直径上的困难
你一个每个模型你出来。
我们不是
发paypal就结束。
走下一个paypal。
我们要去
帮助使用者去用
那只要每个模型出来。
我们就要维护
要解决问题
然后当你有数个模型的时候。
就是
很辛苦
背多着力寡
然后影响到你
迭代的速度
所以在做
一的时候是在
D写的过程当中
然后还快速做二
然后再做二的同时。
就理解到
不行
就是这样做不长久。
所以就决定要做这个。
omni
model的war model。
就是cosmodel。
然后就数个方向
第一个
是秒数同一个世界。
所以其实是可以
合在一起的
然后第二个
fondation model就是。
吸收各式各样的data。
合在一起
然后在开发上也简单很多。
所以就是走向的cosmodel。
调到
所以二到三其实是一个。
大的变化
是的
一到二的变化是
等于是数据的提升。
还有一些那时候
在二的时候
发起来
是有一些变化
但我觉得
二到三是一个很大的。
一个gap
三做了多久
三从去年十月开始做。
就是刚好发了
二之后
十月分发的二
对
其实那时候在
大概是更早的时期。
就知道说必须要做三。
然后
但那时候已经开始了。
2.5
然后把2.5收尾。
然后把2.5收尾之后。
大概做三
所以可能
三可能就是
大概是9月的时候。
开始知道说
要做三
那我真正执行
可能就是十月十一月。
然后做了将近半年。
对 超过半年
一个中国做世界模型的。
创业者
他说他看cosmodel3。
论文看了一周
而且是每天看
里面有很多的细节。
我觉得他们的
观点是说就是
觉得cosmodel3。
他在技术的
大的创新上
不多
但是他把很多的
细节都
工程验证出来了
你觉得还有没有
这个评价重课吗？
mitual transformer。
之前有人提出
嗯
然后parsimodo。
之前有人提出
我们是第一个
把这个mitual transformer。
scale
到这么大的模型
把audio
video
action
都和在一起
然后
这些东西
从概念上来讲
就是东西和在一起。
但你真正要把它
做出来
不是那么容易
嗯
那真正做出来
就是这些细节
所有的
这些大语言模型
都是transform的架构。
你可以讲
大家都没有创新
嗯
但是他的那些细节。
会让这个
某些模型比
另外一些模型好很多。
我认为就是
这么多年之后
我就更加重视
那个
这东西能产生的效果。
我就往往
越来越不重视
这些东西是不是
革命性的一个
原创
对
对我来讲
它有用产生impact。
解掉大家能
想解掉问题
是它的重点
对
那这个paper。
我们是
希望帮助整个
开源社区
就是做开源模型
帮助到整个physical AI。
那我们这几年
看到的现象就是
这些frontier lab。
很多都走向必源
然后即使写paper。
也不愿意讲出
那些关键的环节
嗯
那我们决定走
不一样的道路
我们把能讲的东西。
都讲得
就是把
就是尽量把东西讲。
讲得非常的清楚
然后能
就是我们开源
这个模型也开源
我们怎么去训练
这个
这个模型的框架
然后
部分的这个
synced data。
我们都开源了
我们是希望保持透明。
让大家看到怎么做。
也希望别人
可以利用
我们开源东西
做出跟cosmo。
类似的东西
如果他没有这个兴趣的话。
我们目标就是
enable
这整个community。
对
我不担心
别人可以说出
一模一样的东西
嗯
我想到
你刚才提到Deepseak。
你选择开源
跟他有关系吗？
嗯
也不算是
有关系
就是
Deepseak。
他的工作
对整个AI的影响。
非常的深远
第一个
把mature of。
这个开源的一个公式。
然后你看他
最近的模型
他的用心
把这个
把这个逼到机制
这些对整个领域都。
产生了深远的影响。
嗯
我觉得这很重要
从这影响的角度来看。
我觉得是相通的
我们也是想产生影响。
把这些细节都讲出来。
NVIDIA
有很多
这个
建在NVIDIA Ecosys上面的。
Fysical AI的公司。
然后我们希望
保住他们成功
我们的目标
可能跟Deepseak是不一样。
对
我们是希望帮助
我们的使用者成功。
你们天然就是这个神态了。
对
我们就是希望
就是那个
希望可以
帮助这个
这个Fysical AI。
降临世界快一点
嗯
你们在这次
为什么选择
首先在输入层
同时能够输入
预言
video audio。
和action
这是一个重要的决策吗？
是
我觉得就是
这个世界不是只有视觉。
对吧？
也有听觉
嗯
但我也想加入触觉。
但触觉的讯号
还不好
这个touch sensor。
这些东西还
啊？
觉得还在快速迭代当中。
这个需要零敲手
对
需要零敲手
需要数据
那
我觉得
大模型啊？
基本上
思路有两个
一个是
让
language当成first car citizen。
就像
coding啊？
像chat
嗯
像视觉讯号
video当成是first car citizen。
像cdance
像view
我们认为
物理世界的模型跟。
这个数字世界的模型。
最不一样的地方就是。
物理世界的agent。
会take action。
会改变这个
世界的状态
嗯
我们认为
一个好的物理世界的。
foundation model。
也要把action。
当成first car citizen。
嗯
就是为什么我们把。
language。
然后video
跟action和在一起。
建这个cosmos。
嗯
我记得以前杨志玲。
跟我说
他们做语言模型
他就是把语言
当做最重要的
智能提升的工具
对
他们会很担心Vision。
加入进来
就是影响他的智商。
成为一个
傻的多模台
是
但是谢塞宁
今年又跟我说
他说他担心语言
对于视觉的污染
对
他觉得
语言才是人类的
脚手架
并不本质
这是他的观点
是
你怎么看待
他们这两种观念
以及你把他们
这些信号
都训到一起的时候。
会出现问题吗？
就互相的污染
这些信号
他们带进来
都有他们的目的
嗯
就是language。
可以把这些
人类的knowledge。
带进来
然后也帮助
人类跟这个
这物理AI
做沟通
对吧？
然后video是。
大量的视觉资讯
或者audio
大量的听觉资讯
去描述
这个世界怎么运作。
嗯
那这个
用这个video。
更精准的去
capture
这个世界的物理运作。
用language。
反映很难
对吧？
但是
人
跟这个模型
这个模型之后
建出来是要服务人的嘛？
那你
他不懂language。
你是没办法
跟他沟通的
然后这个
这个模型之后
是要帮助
这些machine。
去take action的。
所以他不懂action。
他是没办法
这个世界的
应该这样讲吧？
就是
我们的目的不同
对
我的目的是希望
这成为一个
好的fondation model。
来
for physical AI。
他需要懂language。
需要知道
这个东西怎么变动。
然后action。
然后既有这个
counter用把它合在一起去做。
那我的目标
不是去追求AGI。
对
然后
AGI本身
也很难去定义嘛？
当你定义的AGI。
就是纯粹要去
解
这个
了解这个
人类的本质的时候。
或者怎么？
去做coding的时候。
可能这些视觉信号。
会影响到你
那是必然的
对吧？
遥远的古代
是没有任何语言的。
然后这些人类的文明的。
发展就是
经由这个
看这个世界怎么变动。
而产生的
那你可以觉得
因为
毕竟这个
这个语言是发展适合。
人类的
但你不知道机器
是不是接受这一套。
也许你就从这个
视觉信号里面
直接去学这个世界。
然后发展出
另外一个文明
那你从角度看
也许语言信号
是一种干扰
那我觉得
是看你要的是什么？
我很明确的
知道我要的是什么？
所以我觉得
我需要Language。
让人可以跟
这个物理AI沟通。
我需要Video。
Audio
去描述
去从这个物理世界的。
变化
就是去学会
这个物理
本质
需要Action。
因为我希望
它最后是可以
自己过来去改变
这个世界
对
所有魔态融合到一起。
这些魔态是相互
Benefits的。
还是相互制约的
在过去
一年
甚至超过一年之间。
我们都一直在研究。
把这些魔态的融合。
那
我们从各个
不同的研究里面
得到一些线索
在Cosmo散射。
把它接在一起
也说在Cosmoparsie。
那片Walker里面。
我们就发觉
Video跟Action合在一起。
是帮助Action的。
对 就是
当你在
直接Pretty Action的时候。
就是
当我们在做Wall Action Model的时候。
我们发觉就是
除了Pretty。
你要做什么Action。
你也Pretty。
接下来
Take the action 之后。
会产生的States。
就是Observation。
是帮助你做兴训练。
或者收敛
所以我们知道
Pretty
那个Video
是帮助Action的。
这是
Wall Action Model的。
这套系列
那
声音也可以帮助Audio。
声音也可以帮助Video Generation。
当你知道
一声碰到个点
你就知道接触的时间。
是那个点
所以知道
这个是有互相
互扶的
然后
一般做Video的人。
都知道
就是
从文字
到Video
这是一个
训许量
变大的过程
训许量变大
代表说
有很多种可能性
很多种可能性的
方式是比较难去学习的。
就是
一种东西可能有失踪可能。
这东西就
没有固定的Target。
不好学
所以在做Video。
或Image
大家都会发觉
就是当你的
那个文字描述
非常强劲的时候
这是比较容易产生。
好的Video
所以
你可以知道
就是文字的
详细描述
也可以表扬这个Video。
那
我们
做Cosmo3
就是想把
之前
这些CosmoReason。
CosmoPredict。
CosmoTransfer。
CosmoPass。
这东西
合在一起
本身就有它的好处。
整个东西就简化
那
这些讯号
怎么合在一起
让它产生
互补的作用
而不是互相
抗拒的作用
这是可以
经由实验的设计
经由Data的
比例的调整
来达到的
所以我们那时候是。
坚信着
这些讯号
都是
描述同一个世界
这些讯号
都含有
这个视觉
怎么运作的资讯
是应该有一种
方式
让它们合在一起
互相帮助
更多讯息
帮助你了解
这个背后的
运作的原理是什么？
对 所以
有这样的不利
那我从这方向出吧？
在这里面有什么？
secret sauce吗？
在互相担任
其实做大模型
没有什么secret sauce。
做严格的实验
假设
实验
看到结果
累积知识
再做下个实验
就一步一步
往下做
走扎实的做就对了。
没有什么？
我不觉得有什么？
就是
不可告人的秘密
就是你要追求的东西。
耐心
做实验
验证
对了
下一步
就这样走
因为你们这次
采取的是一个
双塔的设计
一个塔在处理
离战信息
连续信息
为什么采取这个设计。
有很多个原因
Eks的时候
Cosmode Reason就是离散的。
从Vision Language Model出发。
Predate Transfer Path。
其实是连续的
所以
我们知道离散的
work for understanding。
我们知道连续的
work for generation。
放在一起
就是一个
现阶段很合理的
一个选择
然后再就是
有很多种用Cosmode的方法。
但常用的是
做Post Training。
就是
也许用你的
video action。
的配合
来Train Generator。
或者是
你只想用Reason了。
就是用你
当自己Domain的。
Understanding Data来Train。
当你有两个
这样可以
合在一起
可以把规定的影响。
切开的
是帮助客户去使用的。
如果我们全部连在一起。
好
就是Generation跟Understanding。
在一起了
我现在要
换Generational Distribution。
在换的过程中
因为全部都连在一起。
你的Data
也会改变你Understanding那边的。
表现
如果你没有两个套。
而你是一个的话
Understanding那边。
既然要改变
那你的Data
又没有Understanding的Data。
同意Understanding的。
部分就流失了
那就不方便客户使用。
所以
分成两个
对使用上
是有一定的帮助的。
虽然它
相对起来
还是不够Elegant。
因为你还是要
视线决定它的架构。
在整个Depnding就是。
让Data来决定。
就是怎么说
而不是你人为去
去做区分
但是在这个阶段
我觉得这个东西
是比较合理
比较适合它的使用。
那
讲到这个东西
大家可以猜出来就是。
我们下一步目标
是更加简单一点
为什么有两个套
一个套有够
但是我们在往
一个套的目标前进的时候。
我们要考虑到
这些使用者
是不是容易用上它。
因为我们不是
我们的目标是
帮助大家赢
而不是自己
就是产生一个
就是可以做很多
事情的模型
我们相信
机器人每个都不太一样。
有个
相机的数量
相机的位置
然后自动车
每个都不太一样
我们需要
我们觉得需要克制。
那我们要
机子合在一起
去追求这个
工程的这个
简约完美
我们要考虑到
使用者是不是有办法。
去利用它
那就是我们必须
要研究的课题
但是相对来说
离散的信号更好处理。
把融合进了
连续的变量之后
它的处理难度
会变高
你们怎么合在一起。
并且能够把它
skew上去呢？
对 现在
有一系列的
work像transfusion。
它是可以同时
处理这个
离散跟连续的
在做net token prediction的时候。
它是做离散的
在做defusion是连续的。
然后这段时间
有很多种不同的
变异
大家在研究这个
大家都关切的问题。
这些信号
可以用离散表示
也可以用连续表示。
我是希望
也许是不是开发
这种架构
全部离散
或者全部连续
让事情相对
变得更简单一点
但是这个理想
也不确定能不能成功。
也要做
一步一步的实验验证。
往下走
直接来看
离散更容易
还是连续更容易
各有各的好处
离散比较好
做训练
连续
它有它的
漂亮的地方
在做infant时候。
他们俩是很不一样的。
一个shade
最关键的就是
做客户还是要部署。
部署的时候
一些成本的考量
都很重要
所以我觉得
最后就是会根据
部署是最适合
什么样的模型
最适合部署
我觉得是最容易
获得成功
所以有很多的方向。
要具体在这里考论。
有一个研究员问你。
因为你现在是把
所有的模台
都训到一个模型里去。
那理论上
它也可以
coding做得很好。
也可以让机器人
能够运作
然后也能够生成
我们现在
这种创作者的内容。
那它有可能
在单一维度
比如说coding上。
比cloud还要强吗？
我还是喜欢讲
这个孙子兵法
讲的备多者利管
对
就是如果你什么？
都要好的话
就是在训练过程当中。
你要薄学多文
你要触碰很多
不同的劣别
让你提升你知识水平。
当你确定你只需要。
用这个单一的
application的时候。
是不是有些调整
是
因为你不care。
其他东西的
有没有东西
是你愿意放弃
然后就是做得比较好。
因为如果你什么？
都不愿意放弃的话。
你就会大得很辛苦。
我觉得策略往往就是。
关乎着你决定
你可以放弃什么东西。
这双台之间
会互相的提升吗？
我们知道就是
我们在这个paper。
没有一个实验
就是说
当你用更接近
physical AI的resonance的话。
可以帮助你
做更好的physical AI。
然后
我们也知道
就是说
如果你可以把
generator的规点。
传回resonance的话。
理论上是可以帮助。
你的resonance。
做更好的
就是representation学习。
在这个paper里面。
受训于时间
我们并没有做成完整。
我们想做的实验
已经很多实验了
但是就是
这件事情
整个foundation model开发。
本身就是一个很好事。
一个决定
这是都是
两三个月前就做了。
很难快速的去做一些。
就是跳整
然后我们是
我们不把这个
三看的是一个终极。
就是
我们会继续做
3.1 3.2
一步一步往下提升。
把一些我们想做
进去的能力
想做的一些研究
这是没有机会
把它给呈现的
继续补下去
除了可能会更简单。
双台有可能会变成。
一个台
还会有什么？
未来模型中
可能大家会看到的。
一些变化
我们很关注的
就是这个模型
怎么去帮助
那个Physical AI的Builder。
然后这个模型
推出去之后
据我说之
就是大家都在讨论。
然后有些
Pathen
一些同学都给了
蛮不错的feedback。
泛化是一个核心的问题。
任何AI的核心的问题。
在物理世界的AI里面。
我觉得一种
我们需要达到的泛化。
就是假设我今天
教机器人说
我的衣服我喜欢这样折。
然后我喜欢这样放。
我就给这个机器人看。
一两次我怎么做
它是不是就可以快速学会。
在现实生活中
就快速学会这个东西。
然后是不是给这个。
Physical AI读了说明书。
他就知道
怎么去操作这个仪器。
怎么在这个工厂里面。
做检测
我觉得这些东西
是很重要的能力
是Physical AI打倒的。
那当然这些
在落地的时候
有很多考量
我是想说
在这个Foundation Model 部分。
是有什么东西
是我们能做的
然后可以来帮助
这些Physical AI的Developer。
所以我们中间的提升。
可能都是会朝着这些。
提升这些泛化能力的。
角度来去
把这些东西
加进 Cosmo 模型里面。
比如说你们为这个。
有哪些具体的优化。
优化是像家属那些。
是一定会发生的
我们
我们当然是希望
这个模型可以
就是越跑越快
然后
然后另外一些优化。
就是能力的优化
泛化的优化
那这个东西就是
可能会改
一些架构上
或是一些
training objective的改变。
用一些
特殊的
就是 Q-ray的data。
来做这个训练
不是很清楚
是要测试
它还是一个实验科学。
对 是实验科学
就是
我常常觉得那个
Deep Learning。
就很像中医一样
就是试出来的
试出来的
对
然后那个
在试的过程当中
你做详细的实验记录。
从里面去理解
那个中间的法则
然后我觉得
这是
是很有趣
这两个东西
我觉得很像
然后
我觉得做严格的实验。
控制变数
然后得到一些关键的结果。
是
这是模型
迭代的重要的那个。
一部
也有严谨员提出
这个模型的语言渲染。
是不是可以
把它的比重
加得更大一些
因为他们还是认为。
LLM是提升智能的关键。
你认可吗？
我觉得
在
早期的这个
Image Generation的研究。
包含Image
Google的Image。
里面就提出了
当你的
Language的Understanding越强。
你用更大的T-Fi Model。
你的Image Generation能力更强。
我是相信的
你用更大的
Semitic Representation。
应该要帮助
我是同意的
毕竟
Physical AI的应用。
跟这个
大家常讲的
歌coding
或者chat
还是不太一样
所以
还是需要
做一些实验的验证。
我想做的事情是
了解真正的痛点
然后
从这痛点里面去
去找到合适的方式。
来把这个模型能力补强。
有些大家得到的讯号。
那更好的这个模型。
那么当你没有
资源的限制收益
当然是不放进去
好 但
比较有挑战的就是。
当你资源有限的
收益怎么做取舍
嗯
所以也许
对于场景来说
智能可能不是
那个最关键的辩量。
你需要你的机器人。
会觉得奥数问题吗？
会解这个coding的问题吗？
我觉得你可能
更关注他能不能
把你的
那个工厂
要组装的东西做好。
或家庭的卫生
就是把它
这些操作把它做好。
对吧？
所以我觉得
这个你要解的问题。
似乎是跟
这些大语言
模型公司
这种agent公司。
解的东西是
有点不太一样
然后所以
既然是不一样的题目。
然后最后
解
这个题目的成本
都是一个重要的
如果商业化
最后成本都是
一个重要的考量
那在这些条件之下。
它的架构
真的会跟
现有的这些
for agent的模型。
是一样的吗？
这个是我
一直在思考的问题。
你现在有初步的答案没有。
有没有一些直觉
我觉得
就是
纵观人类的历史
答案就是
应该是不一样
对吧？
然后你
你要做
跟田的工具
跟你要做
仿制的工具是不一样的。
所以
直觉上也是不一样。
最后就是
背多着利果
是吧？
老祖宗的智慧
还是蛮管用的
Cosmos
你们未来
会投入多少卡和资源。
这个我们一直在
卡一直在提升当中。
我不知道我这边
方方面讲
这个卡的数量
但就是
我们希望
我们已经在万几了。
然后希望可以再
更多更多
这会是
英伟达最重要的一个。
模型的项目吗？
英伟达有数个模型项目。
然后
我们主要是把它分成。
两类
一个叫
agent.ai。
就是要做
这个coding chat。
然后去agent.com。
这种digital。
Integent的。
这一套
这些客户的需求
在这里面
我们有这个Nemo床的模型。
就是他们
这个团队
最近released。
这个Nemo床
Ultra
得到蛮不错的效果。
那在Fysical.ai。
这边主要就是Cosmos。
这个模型
Cosmos是一个。
Base Model。
是一个Babble Model。
那Amedia
也很关注自动车
也很关注机器人
然后也关注工厂
对我们而言
这些都是
Fysical.ai的运用。
那在自动车上面
我们就有叫做
Apamayo的Ether。
它是在Cosmos上面。
做的specialization。
就是我们
做自动车
所需要做的这些优化。
那固五次是
在Cosmos上面。
做对机器人
相关的用法
还包含这些
Hope Party。
Control的这些东西。
我是把这些
做自动车
内部做自动车
做机器人
这些看成是
也是我的客户
然后也希望
帮助他们成功
然后在Fysical.ai。
这边就是Cosmos。
为核心来去
辅助这些
主要的Downstream。
的这个
开发者可以获得成功。
所以主要是两个
你说是不是最重要呢？
这两个都很重要
Digital AI。
这个怎么用Agent。
怎么说Coding很重要。
那Fysical AI也很重要。
很难讲是谁比较重要。
对 但现在
打得最火热的就是。
这些Agent AI的东西。
那Fysical AI是下一步。
Fysical AI。
在你们看来
会是一个多大的市场。
这个应该是一个
巨大的市场
我不确定
这个估这个市值
不是我的专业
然后我也不方便代表工资。
想多打
但是
这个
随着人口的老化
随着最制造业的
自主的需求
然后
还有各式各样的
应用
我们觉得这将是一个。
巨大的市场
嗯
因为世界模型
现在缺乏有效的
评估方法
你们有一些
好的探索吗？
世界模型
大与人模型
大家都在追求
更好的
评估检测的方法
然后
就是一般来讲
模型的评测有三步。
第一步呢？
就是benchmark。
就是有一些
固定的data set。
你去
上面两侧
它的quarty。
然后第二种是
arena style。
就是a跟b
看谁比较好
那第三种呢？
就是
跟着asper
去真正有这个痛点的人。
去解这个问题
那
我觉得这三个都很重要。
在physical eye里面。
第三个特别重要
因为每个
就coding agent。
大家都在解coding的问题。
digital use是问题。
但physical eye。
每个要解的问题
不太一样
对
然后
所以我觉得更加强调。
就是跟这个客户
跟这些
运营企伙做的合伴。
一起去了解
怎么样去
评估一个模型
真正有用还是没有用。
这不是一件容易的事情。
这个是给模型发展。
指引方向的重要一步。
我觉得在未来的发展当中。
这一步会越来越重要。
数据也是一个难点。
你们这是怎么做的。
数据是一个难点
尤其是在physical eye。
更是困难
因为
physical eye。
每个形体都不太一样。
然后收集数据
你没有那个
physical setup。
就没有法去收集这个数据。
然后在因为
大家都更加的困难。
因为我们是要
服务各个physical eye的。
这个开发者
每个的机器人都不一样。
所以
我们能做
就找最容易共通的。
觉得就是physical eye data。
主要有两种
一种是
navigation的data。
从a到b
另外一种是manipulation的data。
怎么用
那个
手或是tool
去操作
完成
计定目标
那
navigation data。
比较容易做
就是
你cama怎么动。
车怎么动
机器人怎么动
这些都可以收集
那机器人a跟b
即使他们很不一样。
但他动起来
就是在空间中
位移
有时候可能加一些旋转。
所以是比较相同的。
那操作这边
就比较复杂
我们发现一个趋势就是。
大家越来越追求
接近人手
这种
这种机器手臂
然后论点就是说
这世界
人类的世界
是建出来给人类用的。
所以大部分的工具。
都是适合人手去操作的。
那
整个ai呢？
需要大量的数据
然后
如果你的数据越好取得。
你就能更快得到突破。
所以大部分的
收集数据者是人
人就是手
所以两个环境
两个条件
就是
人手适合收集数据。
然后
这世界是大部分
建给人手的
所以就今天看到
大家往人手的方向。
前进
那所以
我们在这个cosmos。
的时候
也就是
特地把这个
ego sentry的data。
给加进去
包含了
这个人眼怎么看这东西。
从低人称
然后还有人手怎么？
去操作这个物钱
所以
因为我们的目标
不是
去做出一个机器人。
我目标是
帮助大家
可以做出很好的机器人。
所以我们要找
最容易可以
互通的工具
那我觉得
ego sentry data。
是非常重要的
在刚才说的那些
现在的限制和局限之下。
因为大家有
显著的一些优势吗？
在英伟达
获得GPU运算的成本。
比较
比较便宜
毕竟我们生产GPU嘛？
然后再就是
我们在
physical AI。
这边已经生更多年了。
我们有这个sore。
这个chip
然后也有这种
iSAC simulator。
然后就是
所以我觉得
这东西和在一起
我们提供
更多的工具来满足。
各式各样
physical AI。
开发者所需要的需求。
那
还有这点是
我们是真心想
帮助其他家工是成功的。
因为我们
就是我们很清楚
自己能提供的
服务在哪里
然后
比较不会有这种
一直就是
比较
我觉得客户
往往比较愿意
跟我们一起合作
因为我们是
我们不会说就是
跟你做一模一样的东西。
就是
这不是我们的目标。
这个模型
让你非常满意的一点。
是什么？
然后让你有点遗憾的。
可能是什么？
满意的一点就是
我当初跟大家讲说。
可以把过去的
所有模型合在一起。
还会做
比全部
之前的模型都要好。
这件事情发生了
我们现在的模型
比过去单独独立的模型。
效果都要好
那时候很多人不相信。
我觉得很开心
然后第二个就是
这个是我们第一次。
就是
把整个团队
原本是建造数个模型。
现在合在一起建一个模型。
这样把这么大的一个组织。
大家凝聚在一起
去建个模型
我本身也很骄傲
这件事情可以
顺利的发生
遗憾的是什么？
我觉得我们的模型。
就是
因为时间的限制
其实
我觉得模型
还可以继续提升
但是因为时间限制。
我们没有让它完全收敛。
就必须要退出了
然后还有很多
想要改的地方
在
之前都没有时间改。
那
所以就是
觉得这些方式
毕竟就是
想要追求
更好的结果
那
时间有限
好
好处就是
我们继续会做3.1。
3.2
会把之前没做到的东西。
再把它补进去
你有想过
像老黄说的
做到97代
或是什么样子吗？
那时候听到97代。
我的理解就是
我没有决心
就是一路把它做下去。
把它做好
然后
这是一个很大的
commitment。
因为
这个做的模型
是很耗费支援的
然后
它展现出它的决心。
就是往下走
我得到的信心
就是这个东西
会一直往下走
那世界模型
最后就是
接近这个世界
对
从透过那模型
你可以去
学习你想在真实世界。
里面学习的东西
那我觉得就是
是往那方向走
那
最接近的就是
你有能力
随时可以做出
一个
黑可丽国的举声
我觉得就是
最多的样子
那我不确定
是不是需要到97代。
你看
我们如果
就是每半年以来的话。
还要
40几年
对吧？
对
然后我觉得
现在AI发展的速度极快。
也许不需要到40几年。
因为你们团队
又有做
数字世界的模型
也有做
Physical AI的模型。
你觉得训练
两种模型的
差别是什么？
差别大吗？
这个目前的状态
是这样
就是在Nimo床那边。
他们用一个叫做
Hybrid Architecture。
就是某些城市
这个传统的transformer。
但某些城市
这种Mamba style的。
接近RN的
这种架构
那这样的架构
有它的好处
因为
这种RN的运算是比。
在Infant的时候的运算。
是比
这种transformer。
是便宜的
然后Agen
有一堆token。
要产生
有时候你要token。
要Agen
做很久的事情
所以这个是
运算成本的需求
那Physical AI。
这边
我们的架构
就不再从这个路线。
还是走
比较传统的transformer。
但是我们走到
这个Mitual Transformer。
然后把这个Action加进去。
所以这两边的模型的发展。
是
就是渐渐有点不太一样。
但我们两个团队之间。
紧密合作
你可以在Cosmo3的。
这个paper里面。
发觉很多作者
是从Nimo床来的。
然后我们就是
跟他们合作
吸取他们的经验
然后一起去建一些模型。
在未来这两个模型。
有可能统一成
一个更大的模型吗？
这都是有可能
我们的决策很简单。
怎么样可以帮助
科武最好
我们就这么说
我们是很low ego的。
刚才你也提到
Cosmos是一个非常大的团队。
对
你觉得驱动这么大的。
一个团队一起工作。
难点是什么？
我印象中
论文行有290多人。
不到300人对吧？
对
就是
这个团队非常的大。
然后
我是这样看的
这是一个
组织架构的团体
你希望所有人目标一致。
但你又希望
所有人可以自主做决定。
当
全部人的目标
一致
但每个人都不能做决定的时候。
进展会很缓慢
因为只有少
部分的决策者
可以做决定
那这些决策者
假设只有我能做决定。
只有我能决定
这个
这个data的比例怎么挑。
只有我能决定
这个架构怎么做
那我们这个
模型就不会成功
因为我的知识有限。
然后我的时间有限。
然后
我们需要的就是
每个人
都可以做出
对这个
组织
对这个模型发展
重要的决定
那第二个事情就是。
如果大家都可以做决定。
但大家目标不一致。
我就是想把
action做好。
我完全不管
video怎么样。
然后我就是想
understanding做好。
完全不管其他的
这样就会发散
然后可能就产生
不同的架构
然后可能就进一步。
有赛马的行为
那我觉得
跑这么大的一个
重要就是让大家的。
目标一致
但每个人
又可以做出决定
然后这在
组织架构上面
我花了很多心思
去设计一些
团队运作的
这个合作的方式
让资讯透明化
让每个人都有
足够的知性去做出。
对组正确的决定
那当然我们也
提供了容错的空间。
因为
当然一个人害怕
他决定错误的时候。
他是不会做决定的。
所以你要让他们
可以做决定
但也要接受
有些决定会错误
但是错误的时候
要能快速修正
这些都是需要
一些时间
跟一些训练
才能让整个团队
可以朝着方向前进。
怎么让两百多个人。
都同时做决定
这个好难
大家都清楚
整个关键
整个跨决之后
要打到目标是什么？
你要一直去
把未来给化清楚
跟每个人讲
在Cosmos3。
paper出来之前。
或做完之前
我就跟
主要的几个lead。
还有各大部分团队。
都已经讲过说
我们做出来的模型。
会是这样子
那是不是完全这样子呢？
可能百分之九十相似。
百分之十不相似
但是当大家都看到。
同一个愿景的时候。
就比较容易集中
就像你在
在一个篮球选手
你在罚球之前
你都会想象
这个球空心落网
就先把那个目标给盯出来。
然后大家在朝着方向前进。
那当然每个人
扮演的角色不一样。
然后但大家看到
同一个pitch的时候。
就比较容易在
他的岗位上
做出对这个团队
正确的决定
你设计了什么样的管理方法。
让大家的信息
能更透明
能更好的协作
有什么样的管理的技巧。
多用点心思
要解这个
怎么样讲
大家会懂
注重沟通
不开立会这样的会议吗？
我是一个
就是文讲就团结合作。
所以我们的会很多。
但是不是每周一次。
我们每周可能十次有。
每周
应该超过十次
超过十次
所有人还是多少人。
跟主要的立的
每个
比如说我们做video的。
就是定期开会的
一周两三次吧？
然后做understanding。
也是定期
一周两三次
然后还有各个
环节的就是两三次。
就是会蛮多的
然后会议上
可以做一些沟通
那当然会议
大家会觉得就是开会。
有时候很没有效率。
尽量做一件事情
就是让每个会议
都更加engaging。
然后让每个人都能参与。
这都是需要一些训练。
让这个团队这样
那永远不会最搞笑。
你可以
大家都不开会
各做各的
那不见得会成功
你可以一直开会
什么都不做
只是假
也不会成功
你就要选一个均衡。
在不同的时间点
会有不同的一种
调配方式
那这个东西都是
因任务因死而定
而没有说
一定的公式
拿给另一位人
就是最好
你看桂谷
现在大家说
Open Eye的企业文化。
是自小而上
Andropic是自小而下。
你们属于哪一种
我们是都有
一个都会走向极端。
天下分久必合
和久必分
东西就是物极必反。
我觉得都是要掌握。
在那时间点了解
什么是对这团队
最正确的事情
而不是一味的
损着一个方向
一个模式的操作
我理解Cosmos的。
爆发的时间点
和Physical AI。
和机器人的爆发
可能会有
是正相关的
对吗？
你觉得这个市场
引来一个
所谓的ChargeGbd Moment。
大家都在追求
这个Physical AI的。
TrueGbd Moment。
什么叫TrueGbd Moment。
跟Gbd Moment有什么不一样。
Gbd Moment是跟我们讲说。
东西可以Scale。
Scale之后
模型能力会更强
TrueGbd Moment是。
让大家清楚看到了。
这样的一个Scaling。
这样一个好的模型。
对人的生活
会产生什么样的变化。
大家发觉这是一个。
有智能体
可以跟他沟通
可以问一个
知识广播的朋友
什么叫TrueGbd Moment。
Physical AI。
应该是指说
大家看到一个
以AI为主的
Enabled Physical AI的应用。
让大家清楚看到说。
这东西是真的有用。
这东西什么时候会发生。
这真的很难去预测。
但我看到是
整个领域
对Physical AI的兴趣。
越来越大
有越多资金
越来越多
越来越多的
有智者
创立公司
下去解较这个问题。
Physical AI可以利用。
在Digital AI上面的成功。
所以我觉得各项条件。
都逐渐在收敛当中。
我是希望尽快看到。
TrueGbd Moment。
尤其今年
尤其明年
我不知道
但是我觉得它必然会发生。
你觉得人性气认
会在这个赛道里面。
成为主流吗？
我觉得人性气认
它的优势就是
可以利用大量的
人的数据来获得
学习的素材
来提升这些效果
但人性气认
它本身
越像人有腿 有手。
这些东西就是
相对的复杂度
也比较高一点
很多人都来做轮型的。
只有上半人是人
但下半人是一种移动平台。
这样的平台
也可以解掉很多问题。
你说这样的是人型机器人。
我觉得也是
就是翻身像人
也不是全人型
像全人型的某些人型。
也更接近人型
有些人型不要不接近人型。
我觉得人型机器人。
终究会是一个
重要的关键
但是多像人型
这件事情
大家都在
尝试当中
我觉得最终
全人型是最
最适合各式各样的操作。
因为这个人类的环境。
就是设计给全人型的。
但最后还是要
关键还是这个营运成本。
到底怎样是最
最经济效率最高
那这就超乎我的专场。
我其实不知道
那我的目标是满足。
帮助这些各式各样的。
Physicology Builder。
我也不需要做卷选择。
我就是拎拎他们的声音。
看我们的模型
怎么做可以更加帮助他们。
Deep Mind谭杰老师。
他有一个预测
他是觉得2035年到2036年。
可能是人型机器人。
成为主流的一个拐点。
是吧？
嗯
OK
对我
我希望早一点
但我不确定
你觉得世界模型
可能会有一个
所谓的拐点吗？
我觉得世界模型
并不是新的
这早就有世界模型了。
我觉得世界模型
会一直在做
就是性能的提升
那我们在
大圆模型上面
看到的模型越来越好。
对不对
那我觉得在世界模型上。
有看到的越来越好。
我们这次在Cosmos3。
也做出这个一个
嗯
比较不一样的世界模型。
这种Only Model的Wall Model。
对
所以我觉得还是有一些变化。
然后我会需要一点时间。
去让大家去吸收
因为毕竟这东西
不是这个模型出来后。
直接可以使用
是必须要看怎么调配。
可以在这个
就是机器人场景落点。
那我觉得是需要点时间。
那我觉得这会
会继续变化
对
会一直进步
会一直变化
因为你说
你要为机器人
构建一个黑客帝国吗？
那黑客帝国讲的本身。
就是一个人类
沦为了机器的活体电池。
然后活在一个虚拟世界。
Matrix中
然后一个觉醒的人。
试图挣脱这个系统的寿命。
然后来终结这个循环。
那你现在为机器人。
打造这个Matrix。
如果有一天机器人。
要觉醒了
想要挣脱这个虚拟世界。
怎么办
我用黑客帝国的地方。
是帮大家具象
就是有一个世界模型。
这么快去加速学习。
很多人担心
就是AI
当它能力太强的时候。
会take over the wall。
对 就会把我们给。
iniminate。
那我觉得这个社会。
是人去建立的
这些科技是人在背后操作。
我觉得只要大家是有共识。
我觉得就是这件事情是。
不会发生
然后再就是
我
这就比较哲学一点了。
我觉得
Tank and Suffering。
是一种
驱动人去进步的
一个重要的关节
不是很确定
这些CityCon。
做成的Intelligent。
是不是有同样的
Tank and Suffering。
然后
我心里是产生存疑的状态。
那我当然知道
就是
我们希望这个科技。
可以大幅度的
改善人类的生活
那我们也需要
做出这些
相对应的
就是Garrel来确保。
它就是
不会去影响
这个正常世界的发展。
说到世界模型
其他做世界模型的团队。
会把你当作竞争对手。
因为大家觉得
你也是做世界模型的。
但是你一直在说
我不是你的竞争对手。
你有什么想对他们说的吗？
世界模型这个工具。
对
然后工具是解决的问题。
有好多种不同问题要解。
最终要解的问题
只有世界模型是不够的。
对吧？
取决于你要解的问题。
如果说
因为我们要去服务。
整个世界模型
我们要建设世界模型。
让大家的模型可以用。
然后
世界模型的问题
本身又特别的难
有好多其他问题要解。
那
如果你可以跟我们一起合作。
利用我们做的东西。
那你可以走得更快。
更远
这不是很好的一件事情吗？
对不对
那
让我们都是
采开了的状态
那如果说
你用我们
就是
做出比我们更好的模型。
那这模型
也是开源的
让大家可以用
那我们也是
帮助整个 figure assistant。
所以你只有比我们好。
我们也觉得
这是一件好事
对吧？
我觉得
大家一起团结合作。
去解调困难的问题。
是一件
很值得去做的事情。
那
但彼此间
就是
互相
底处
就是
set high bar。
然后越来越往上爬。
那也是很重要的一环。
你会说
英伟达又想来卖我卡了。
对
那你需要做运算
那我们这个
现在这个
英伟达的生态在这里。
有很多东西
可以让你去
利用的
why not
对吧？
你要做一个生意
都是要做投资的
最重要的是
你的货地是多少
而不是
像这些
cow company。
他买了大量的 GPU。
他赚了更多的钱
对吧？
你们内部会讨论
什么是下一个枯大吗？
有可能是cosmos吗？
过去的软体
是建议逻辑
然后枯大是
帮助
把这些application。
所需要逻辑
转换成GPU的运算。
未来的软体是AI。
为
这核心的
那AI是
be on top of other AI。
然后所以我们觉得。
做的Nemo床
跟这个cosmos。
都可能是
未来的枯大
因为外部
会对枯大有非常多的副盘。
那作为
你的视角
你觉得枯大
是怎么做成功的
还需要具备哪些要素。
像比如说
现在cosmos。
它具备了那些
不具备的是哪些
它是一个可复制的路径吗？
我不
确定
这是不是一个
可
我觉得枯大
当初
提出的时候
是很前瞻性的想法。
很冒险的想法
在
这个
当
都不确定
这个accelerated computing。
会不会是
abyssin的时候。
我们公司就做出了这样。
勇敢的投资
那
我们做的大模型都。
都会于枯大
然后可以往下走
我不会
把这个cosmos。
或Nemo床
跟枯大做
同等的连结
因为我觉得
现在的
发展已经相对
复杂很多
有很多个不同的
整个产业是
很多个stack的。
合在一起的
我觉得合在一起
可能是新的枯大
而不会说
这个模型单一
就是一个枯大
对
你还需要做serving。
你还是要去做
这些infrastructure。
有很多东西
要合在一起
那枯大你们觉得
是哪些要素
共同促成了它的成功。
枯大一开始的时候。
就是在寻找application。
一开始是scientific computing。
然后后来
在deep learning。
出来之后
找到枯大最重要的application。
往下走
那枯大还是一直在。
提供不同各式各样的application。
我觉得复制枯大
是一个很好的想法。
但我不觉得你按照。
原来的路线
就会走一样的路
我觉得这个环境
是不一样的
对
我觉得是要adaptive。
要看清楚
拿个时间
可以做出哪些重要的贡献。
嗯
所以你们不会拿着。
这个锤子去找钉子对吧？
拿着我要做出下一个枯大。
就是当年是一个
非常成功的决定
然后我来做今天的决定。
就像老黄长讲的
它的的确认识
非常first principle。
它是觉得什么合理。
然后再往那个方向走。
而不是找着
纳着的锤子去找钉子。
因为你刚好加入
英伟达十年了
是
这十年你变化大吗？
你在英伟达的这个股票。
涨了多少倍了
一共
对
那个
这些一切都是没有预期到的。
这段时间里面
我们见证到一个
没有人把
AI跟英伟达
连接在一起
变到一个
全世界都把英伟达。
跟AI连接在一起。
到一个
我父母亲不知道什么叫。
英伟达到
全世界都叫什么叫。
英伟达的这个时间。
这是很巨大的变化。
那
中间的历程
也不是那么容易
公司
你从股价来看
就有七七伏伏
我记得那一年
就是
TPU刚出来的时候。
公司股价掉了很大一截。
对
然后有些
同学们在那时
就对公司的
未来产生的
就是不同的想法
也就是例子
但
后来
每年在Lperf里面都。
几百TPU
然后产生出
更好的那个新价比。
那
后来就是只有我们产赛了。
这东西都
都很难去预测
这些变化实在是很大。
那我觉得就是
在这场期间
我更加理解到
什么叫就是慢慢经营。
慢慢去经营
就是找到一个
你相信的目标
非常first principle。
一步一步往下走
你会看着
老皇带着整个公司。
这么大的一个团队。
然后就是一步一步走。
像今天这个
这个
成绩
雨有容颜
就是大张子这样
你当时
家住的时候
没有想到这一切对吧？
你当时还有其他的offer。
但没去
对
不可预期的
我当初加入的原因。
就是因为我想要有GPU。
可以为这个
支持我的学术研究。
是很简单的一个原因。
我某方面来讲
我也是非常first principle。
我觉得GPU是
这个
做科研重要的工具。
我要去一个
GPU众多的地方。
那不如去一个
生产GPU的地方。
另外一个offer。
是谁啊当时
我说的offer。
对
其中有一个投资公司。
他跟我讲说
不管我去哪里
不管对方给我多少钱。
我都给你4倍
然后希望你
可以加入他们的
这我们的公司
可以一起去研究
怎么去用dip能力。
来做投资
我本身对这个东西。
并不是很感兴趣
我还是想做科研
然后还是选择了MVD。
当时MVD
是可能是
更不知名的那一格是吗？
是啊？
对
你觉得你看16年的老黄。
和现在老黄
变化大不大
头发都白了
我觉得他承担的压力。
大了很多
但他还是就是
关心员工
然后很仔细的
去阅读公司的
员工学的top 5email。
然后去找到一些讯号。
来帮助整个公司
往前进步
有很大的变化
公司的规模
很大的变化
我们都加入的时候。
公司可能不到2万人吧？
然后现在已经
两倍以上
可能更多
那时候GPU
都还是桌机
现在都是data center。
那时候没有physical AI。
现在physical AI。
都成为了一个重点。
变化是很大的
你在过程中
有见证
以为答案哪些
pay and software没有。
全程常常在嘴边讲。
他说
当然不是真的
他每次都讲说
他每天都觉得公司。
只剩下30天的
公司
他每天都觉得公司。
只剩下30天的
现金流
30天后就要破产。
现在还这么说
他每天都这样讲
每天都这样讲
每次开会
都是这样提醒自己。
我吓唬高管吗？
就是要求自己
做出对公司
最正确的决定
然后有一年pandemic的时候。
整个就是
经济状况不好
那个时间点
就是很多公司
就开始拆远
那我记得那次
公司大会的时候
我们就决定要拆什么？
我们要拆的就是
travel
就是员工就不用去travel了。
全部都是online。
这样就剩下一笔钱。
然后我们再研究
哪些工具可以不要。
比如说
在硅谷
很多公司都用sac。
来做这个通联
我们来考虑
是不是就不要sac了。
反正我们有email。
然后我们有两个
两三个call
比如说我们有时候用。
用microsoft的。
有时候用google。
是不是可以去消一个。
可以省钱
可以看到公司就是。
在一些困难的时期。
做出一些
相对不平凡的决定。
有些公司会把
裁员来降低这个
就是人事开销
Media想的是。
什么可以节省掉
一些不必要的开销。
照顾员工
一起度过困难的事情。
为什么NVDI一直坚持不裁员。
他真的没有裁过员工吗？
我在英伟达的时间里面。
就是我没有
听到任何裁员的消息。
也没有末尾淘汰对吧？
我们没有
所谓的末尾淘汰
然后就是
我们只有给performance review。
当然就是有些人会。
因为对performance的不满而离开。
然后有些人是
真的有其他的因素就离开。
但我们不会因为
我们改变了产品的方向。
然后或者是因为
就是这段时间内你。
就是performance不好。
而就让你走
我们觉得人跟人之间的信任很重要。
当一个员工对这个公司。
有认同感
有安全感
他愿意讲出一些
就是
可能在一般
担心被淘汰的地方。
不愿意讲的事情
当没有所谓的
末尾淘汰的时候
大家也不会
就是真的这么的
就是这么担心被淘汰。
而抢出头
那在一个
全部都抢出头的地方。
反而不容易促成团结合作。
我觉得这样的一个。
管理模式
会促成一种公司文化。
是跟那些
会做末尾淘汰的
公司文化是蛮不一样的。
他的优点和缺点是什么呢？
我觉得就是
公司员工想敢讲真话。
愿意团结合作
缺点就是
当一项科技
就是逐渐变得
成熟的时候
这些员工需要一点时间。
学习新的东西做转型。
重新学习新的东西。
是需要多一点时间的。
那如果你直接
LateOp在Hire新的一批人。
那你可能可以直接。
害得到一些
已经会这些东西的人。
所以这些
经由转型
做起来是会比较慢一点。
但是你得到
员工的信任
然后也可以
团结合作的员工
组织效率怎么提升呢？
这对你们来说是个问题吗？
就是大家只要充满热情。
然后觉得自己做东西。
是很有意义的
然后整个效率就会提升。
每个人都有选择
那都会想
做自己有成就的事情。
那如果公司可以提供。
这个环境
让大家可以去发挥的话。
那在效率就会提升。
就让每个人可以做出他们最。
喜欢最擅长的事情。
但同时
这些事情对公司
又是有极大的利益的。
只要能抓到这点
我觉得就是一个很好的状态。
平常去不裁员有很多好处。
但是大部分公司
都不是这么做的对吧？
是
这是为什么？
然后以及老王
黄为什么从一开始。
就觉得不应该裁员。
我觉得NVIDIA是一个。
像
长久经营
经营下去的公司
然后
我觉得就是这么多年。
他在
老王在这个
硅谷代这么多年
看到这么多风风雨雨。
他选择这个东西
一定有他的道理
就是
我觉得不是一个随机的选择。
一个伸手绿后
觉得这东西是
是他想要的企业文化。
他想要
公司的运作模式
是不是意味着
当新技术来的时候。
因为打不会是最快的那个。
但是它是依赖于
你早十年
或是早五年的提前布局。
这样他对快就要求不高。
NVIDIA就是头满他手嘛？
然后看得远
你看
KULA就是这样一个案例。
布局的十年
对吧？
所以就是你要有
很强的眼光
然后长期投资
对
你们也不赛嘛对吗？
我们不喜欢赛嘛？
因为我们通常都是。
这样做
就是
你去take the mission。
我们就相信你
但我们一起
给你很高的
的把
希望你完成
就是
用老皇话讲就是
一直让你
那个
接受pain and suffering。
totally you do greatness。
相信你
然后给你
考验
然后不断的磨练你。
让你一步一步往下。
成长
这是我们喜欢的模式。
你在因为大家受过最。
惨烈的suffering是哪个阶段。
做这些大模型
这几年都是这么？
辛苦的在往下走
我刚刚跟你讲那些东西。
很多都是
从错误中学习
很多东西
就是一开始
也没有理解到
这些东西最重要的东西。
那为了把东西做好。
然后
当心做不对的时候。
要怎么慢慢把东西给改进。
我觉得这一段
就是自从
gbt起来之后整个。
这个ai的从业人员。
大家都感受到莫名的压力。
对
然后这段时间里面。
就是这个
迭代的速度啊？
然后大家都
饱受的压力的
我觉得都是pen suffering。
尤其是当你每天
挥撒这些gpu资源。
挥撒这些年轻人的。
时间
然后做出成果
没有打扰你最喜欢的。
结果
我觉得这东西无形上都是一个。
压力
你的生活状态发生。
变化了吗？
在过去几年
高校
早几晚几
我大概是4点到5点起来。
我这么早
早上起来的时候
运动啊？
那些就是时间比较连续。
一到公司之后就一直开会嘛？
然后
10点到公司大概。
大概是9点到10点左右。
因为整个产业的
迭代速度
所以生活布料都变快。
还是
要学东西还是很多。
但处理的事情又变更多。
让自己更加高校
你几点睡啊？
我大概
大概10点左右吧？
10点左右
4点到11点左右。
4点
5点起
对
不是每天都鼓鼎
但基本上是我的常态。
因为达到
书也好
或者老黄的专辑也好。
都讲了很多他的管理方式。
能不能从更一线的视角来讲一讲。
就是因为达到一些。
不一样的管理方式。
我们刚刚可能
设计到一个是不裁员。
第二就是top 5。
员工就是要跟很多人。
就是
讲这个他做的事情。
最重要的无间事情。
这件事情让你看清楚。
就是各种
公司的大小讯号
可以看到
很多两个团队
在做一模一样的东西。
那个top 5一没有。
就会自然显现出来。
NVIDIA是一个。
相对很透明的
一个组织架构
苹果可能是反例
就是
只是我们
就是追求的资讯透明。
然后
当然那个
这也是一个很不一样的考求。
那
那些老黄专辑
有些是比较细续讯。
但很多都是你可以在。
因为大家工作的时候。
就可以感受到
他认识很多员工
我们常常讲
mission is the boast。
然后
因为有时候像是一个。
有机体
没有那么强的框架。
当我们公司今天
要走向这个方向的时候。
在各种不同组织的团队。
但有相对的技能就会。
事动align
就往那个框架傾向。
就是像一个活的组织。
不是一个固定框架。
你在这个里面
就不能出水的东西。
没有关系
你在这个公司
哪里都没关系
但是你要往这个方向前进的时候。
你的团队的
智慧产生贡献的
就全部能就align。
就变成一个新的方向。
往这边走
cosmo就是这样子。
一个案例
就是很多人
他可能不属于这个团队。
但是他都可以来
支持这个团队的工作。
对
mission is the boast。
而不是你的 boast。
是你的 boast。
mission is the boast。
这几个是最具有特色的。
就是
这几个让生公司的。
就是很活
你看
我刚刚讲的
这个mission of boast。
就不是一个
很硬的框架
是个有机体
那这个 tough fight。
让公司各个地方的。
微小讯号
都可以传到
或散出去
对吧？
那不愿意让
就是不信任
layoff 员工。
就是讲究转型
讲究 torture。
让员工对这个公司。
将强信任
然后可以彼此互相合作。
我觉得这几个都是。
因为大家很独特的地方。
嗯
一群 i4 级的人。
一起工作
和一群 a plus。
或 a a 级的人一起工作。
哪个可能取得的成功。
更大呀？
大家在追求就是
一加一大于二
对
然后
是不是大家可以
团结合作
产生更大的效应
是很重要的一件事情。
然后当然
人多的时候
就有一个沟通成本。
然后沟通成本就是负面的。
你等于就是要
人跟人合作给产生。
正相关
但是要
降低这个沟通成本。
那
一群很聪明的人
一起合作
当然大家都很聪明。
很快就理解
然后手脚又快
但是如果人跟人之间。
无法呼吸的话
也很难得
一加一大于二
大家都防备的对方。
不愿意把最好的一面。
呃
展现出来
或者是就是要展现出。
我就是陪你聪明
那这样子
也不见得是一个好的。
状态
那我觉得反正就是。
呃
就像
打游戏一样
你不要整个团队
全部都是弓箭手
跟有些人是负责防御。
有些人是会
呃
是補血的
各项不同的
呃
属性合在一起
我觉得这样多元
是一个比较好的状态。
你看你今天说了很多。
你没有竞争对手
然后你不和任何人竞争。
都是客户
然后大家都是合作伙伴。
这种楼一购的状态。
是在英伟大发生的变化吗？
呃
是就是
这真的楼一购
还是只是一种隐藏。
我觉得是一种
confidence。
是一种自信
嗯
是觉得
呃
我们做出来的东西。
是可以帮助到大家。
那
我的目标是
帮助大家做好
但我对我自己做东西。
我要求很高
我希望它变好
但我的目标并不是。
击败对手
我的目标是
那个
做出好成绩
提出更好的
foundation让大家。
可以动得更快
嗯
这是跟老黄学的吗？
哦对
我受到影响非常深。
嗯
这是什么时候学的。
如果你是一个研究员。
你就是
毕业的方法
就是让你的
论文在
顶级的会议上被接受。
然后
review都会question你的东西。
是不是steal the art。
那你要steal the art。
代表说你要击败说的人。
所以研究员
我这种心态
就是我的东西要比你强。
好
然后所以
寻找这个轨迹
我也就是
一开始就是一个
highly competitive的individual。
就是我东西要做比你好。
嗯
那
这个对于就是
我要求当然好
就是希望东西
越来越好
但久之后就是
你知道就是
你总是steal the art。
一段时间就下一个。
出去吧？
对
就是这东西
一直不断进步
我现在站的位置
也不一样
就是
因为这个管理者之后。
希望就是
培养新一代的人才。
帮他们成长
然后站在这个
NVIDIA这个。
Ecosystem的角色。
也希望这个公司
就逐渐
感受到这个好处
有时候
看到我这些伙伴们。
跟我讲说
用你的模型之后
我解这个效率
提升了很多
然后我就很开心
我觉得
呃
我的
我的付出
整个团队的辛苦付出。
啊？
获得的
一些回响
这种肯定也是
很好的一件事情
不仅得是要几百
啊？
其他才是
一定能产生贡献
你不需要几百你的对手。
我不喜欢把他们
当成是对手
喜欢把他当成是伙伴。
嗯
你看NVIDIA。
包括你
然后包括Jason。
他出来
经常会说
take care of others。
就不管是员工
还是外伯的合作伙伴。
这种take care。
是一种真实的吗？
就是他这是
这么想的吗？
因为一开始的时候。
我们就是
呃
我们就是生产这个。
就是这个design house。
然后最后
我们也没有什么？
consumer product。
都是靠着其他家公司。
帮我们做GPU卡。
我们就是
一直有这个习惯
就是要跟着整个
ecosystem。
一起成长
大家一起穿钱
总不能说
钱只有我们赚嘛？
这些帮忙做这个
显卡
伺服器这些
呃
都要一起能
那个往下走
嗯
因为啊？
早期的
这个显卡
来做游戏
我们也不做个游戏。
对
我们就是
就是一直开发
这些好的library。
帮助的游戏公司
做游戏
我们看开始
走向deep learning。
的时候
那时候好几个框架。
比如说拍头区啊？
tensor flow啊？
还有一些msnet。
这些东西
我们全部都支持
对
然后后来
本来有这个揣摇卡。
拍了
我们是支持
那个揣摇
那von
出来之后
我们支持von
对
就是我觉得是
就是
呃
就是想帮助这些
建在我们
这GPU平台上面的客户。
能更加成功
他们更加成功
代表他们
可以服务更多的客户。
那他们
就有
大量的机会
会使用我们的GPU。
是一种
真的是
功力
一起走向成功的条路线。
嗯
那我觉得是这样
也是他技能
这不多年才吧？
这个公司
放在这么一个
好的位置
让帮助别人
可以获得
功力
我觉得这不容易
嗯
你近距离观察过
呃
老黄很多年
如果只用几个次来形容他。
你会这么形容吗？
我们将他六边形展示。
嗯
就是
不管是
我们有时候开会
他可以
走到很深
去研究这个register。
这个
computer architecture。
这个register。
这个
非常细的细节
同时间又可以长到。
想到
可以就可以教大家。
怎么做marketing。
怎么做这些
非常high-level的东西。
然后在
处理这个
呃
不管是
产品定价
然后跟客户的关系。
他一面一面俱到
然后
就是
他是
极大的热情
他给他所有东西
帮助他的公司
成功
就是一很
很令人佩服的一个。
呃
的操作
各个方面
都可以产生贡献
然后各方面都
尽力做到最好
他是一个很厉害的。
一个人
对你鼓励比较多
还是
呃
批评比较多
一般来说
鼓励批评都有
当我还没有完全理解。
他怎么？
要怎么去跑这公司的时候。
批评是比较多的
但
批评终终只带的
终是带的鼓励
希望你可以变好
他的目标就是
totally everybody to business。
他经由这些母链
让你更加理解
就是怎么样
做台湾做出不平凡的事情。
这很好经历的
你愿意花时间
去totally别人。
这世界不容易的事情。
所以totally别人。
你自己心里
要产生很大的负担。
对吧？
而且你人生
就这么多时间
你可以不管
你可以
也许还是
还是能达到你要的东西。
但是他愿意花时间。
去totally别人。
让大家不断的进步。
这些不容易的事情。
他对你
让你印象深的一句话。
是什么呢？
我觉得有一次
我们在一个会上
我们在比较
两个solutions。
两个东西
然后
我是做其中一个东西的人。
另外一个是
其他人做的东西
然后我记得那时候。
我讲了一句话说
我觉得他们用的setting。
是一个不费的setting。
所以导致这个
那个
所以我们在这方面。
表现就没有
达到我们的预期
落后这个进屏
那
他那时候给我一句话说。
Are you a crybaby。
只是实际上
没有什么是公平的。
你在写论文的时候。
常常讲说
我的setting。
就是
跟你的setting不一样。
所以不能同时比较。
但你的目标
如果是要解决一个问题。
那当然是
是做这个
要解决的问题
所需要的条件
没有这条件
你就会想办法拿到。
那是我
那句话让我印象很深。
可能就是我
更加严格要求自己就是。
找理由是没有用的。
就是这个
就应该give everything you have。
我以前也听过这句话。
细点军校有些著名的。
那个书也是讲的
就是没有理由
no excuse。
对吧？
但他跟我讲
让我的印象就更加深。
毕竟他是一个著名的人物。
那我觉得这句话
对我的影响也蛮大。
我话就不太着理了。
如果当你做一个研究员。
想成为number one。
和英伟达的本身的业务。
因为他不想成为
强劲的竞争对手
如果发生冲突的话。
你会选择哪一个
我觉得那个
就是科学的发展
本身就是incremental的。
就是一直在进步
一直在进步
你随时随地都可以提出。
improvement。
就是在往上带
再走一步
然后
我觉得就是
be the absolute number one。
什么叫
那我这很难去定义。
什么叫number one。
然后我比较喜欢看。
就是一个frontier的模型吧？
对
但frontier的模型。
做出来
那时间是number one。
很有成就感
但之后就会有
其他的模型可以做上去。
我是希望就是
你具备的
就是
做number one模型的能力。
但是
就是
做出
对这个社会影响最大。
最有功心的事情
对
因为你可以做出
number one的模型。
但
你
就是
只是给少部分人用。
然后或者是
就等于
让权力过度集中
在少部分的手里
然后产生一些
不平衡的状态
我觉得不见是
一件对的事情
对
那我
我是希望就是
具备number one的能力。
但是做出
这次世界贡献最大的事情。
具备number one的能力。
但是做出
对这个世界
贡献最大的事情
是啊？
所以最重要的是
后面那个贡献
对吧？
不是那个能力
对
人呢？
就走一遭嘛？
对吧？
然后你留下来就是影响。
这要活的久
活的久机会大一些嘛？
就是希望能产生一些。
做些
贡献
然后
就证明自己
就是没有白来走一遭。
嗯
大概就这样子
你还有什么？
在研究生涯上
觉得遗憾的吗？
你还有什么？
特别想得到的
我觉得
Figure还没有成功嘛？
对
还没有
还没有到那个时间点。
是
就是
谈论这些
我觉得
我很开心那时候
十年前
我在
我在讲
这个
Deepness你会取代。
Computer Graphics。
成为一个
最重要的这种
这种
影像生存的模式
这件事情发生了
我
我觉得还蛮开心的。
这事情真的发生了。
那我觉得
这种世界模型
会是推动Figure。
成功的重要推损
然后这是我
下一个
重大目标
我希望这个东西
也能成功
你要比就是
你有一个
Best Paper Award。
你就会想说
我要拿两个
然后我就造成
现在拿了十几个
你总是拿不完嘛？
对不对
比论文数总是
有更多的论文
那你比采贴人数
总是有更多的采贴人数。
你比钱总是
有人更得有钱对不对。
那重点是
我觉得你
对自己的
东西
是不是
很骄傲
我觉得
过去有很多东西
我觉得我做不够好。
但目前
有些东西
我觉得我做得不错。
那我接受
然后我觉得
就是
在我的能力范围内。
我觉得我做出了
我自己满意的东西。
我觉得
这个不
就外部的
很多衡量指标
现在慢慢都
变得没有那么重要。
对吧？
对
年轻的时候
都觉得他们很重要。
为什么？
这个人的Best Paper。
比我多
对
然后讲比我多
那现在觉得
就是
渐渐的这个
不在于
我中心渐渐转移
帮助别人
对
也许我现在
帮助人够不够多
你最近一年
帮助了谁
这些使用
使用Cosmo的User。
我觉得我都
默默之中
替他们提出了帮助。
然后当然还有自己的团队。
还有一些
就是
就是跟我交换过的人。
我觉得或多少
我对他们生命都
产生了一些影响
你也经常来中国吗？
是
你怎么看中国的
这一批模型的发展。
非常的
Impressive。
Very Impressive。
这些
从Deep Sea开始。
千万
多宝
我都把它全部加一次吧？
Mini Mass Gio。
然后Kimi
然后
这些
Mimo
对
会员
这些
制服
对
都做得很好
还有一件事情就是。
在美国
尤其是这些
Fantia Lab。
现在的状态
就是他们很少
去遭受实习生
很多
No How
很多这些
科研的结果
都只有在
他们自己本身
内部的实验室有
在中国
这边有看到
他们像
这些公司都遭受
很多实际生
然后
帮助把这些
No How
传递出去
然后我觉得
人类整个
就是
知识扩增
就是Diffusion。
对
我觉得是一件好事。
看到这些
快速发展
我觉得
我觉得很Impressive。
然后还
还同时注重到
这些Diffusion。
大家对AI
都充满了热情
就是愿意去尝试
我觉得这都是
我看到的一些现象。
谢谢您跟我说
硅谷已经被LLM。
催眠了
你怎么看到这句话。
我不觉得是
纯粹被LM催眠
不能否认的
就是现在
在AI里面
最领先的公司
就是模型上
不管是OpenAI。
And Drop it。
都是
从大语言模型出发的。
这些模型也确切
我现在已经不知道。
没有Coding Agent。
我要怎么过下去
我也不知道
这些事还太方便
我觉得产生很巨大的。
变化
也不是一件坏事
LM真的
产生了很大的用处。
然后帮助
提升我们的生活
我觉得很自然而然的。
就是
大家会
会想
就是这东西
既然都
都已经在这里了
然后下一步是什么？
我觉得人自然会想。
要做哪件事情
我知道
银云里面有些人是把。
学术变成信仰
但我觉得
大部分人都还是
从
知求真的角度出发。
当一个东西
被充分理解
之后
大家会找到新的东西。
来进行做突破
很难想象一个人就。
这么聪明的人
一辈子就只做LM。
对
我觉得自然而然会发生。
我并不觉得
有这种催眠的事情。
就是
对那些人而言
对现在的时间而言。
也许做LM
是一件很正确的事情。
昨天SpecSats上市。
然后马上OpenL。
AndropiL上市。
今年这些公司
大模型公司的上市。
会对
行业发生什么样的影响吗？
2026年会是
巨变的一年
这边上市
大家都看到新闻了吗？
就是会产生很多富翁。
对吧？
然后我知道
究竟咱的房价
大概快速飙涨
早期相信Deep能力。
早期相信
这个space mission。
这些人就是
这些等于是对他们的。
远见
对他们的勇气
对他们的决心
这一个认同
我觉得都很合理
对
这些公司
这世界产生巨大的贡献。
我觉得完全值得
但
这个
我觉得科技不会停在这里。
然后
陆陆续续
都会有新的事情发生。
100年前强盛的公司跟。
现在强盛的公司
是完全不一样
50年前不一样
20年前不一样
对
我觉得
这个社会
只要
组织架构
还是一个
好的良心的状态
就会不断有创新发生。
对
就模型
这场竞赛的终局
可能是什么样子
短短几年
已经发生这么大的变化。
再往远看呢？
我想这就很conversal。
我觉得模型的能力。
慢慢就会统一
对
靠模型自己
不会是区分
一定要靠一些
其他的东西
组织在一起
领先的模型
有更充裕的时间
去找到区分的方式。
然后
强大的这个公司
也可以夹达自己
强大的eco system。
去做出一些
变化
对
然后我不会觉得
像
Software刚出来的时候。
会写Software公司很少。
现在大家都会写Software。
每家Software都有。
自己的区分方式
那些人活下来的Software公司。
都是有区分公司的。
然后
我觉得没有理由
模型会是
不一样
我觉得
会是一样
所以没有必要
神话模型
或者模型公司是吗？
我把它当成中医啦。
就是一个
这么多人不同常识。
最后就是
一个一套学问
然后很多人都会中医。
对吧？
关键是你要的
它干什么？
对
那有些人
解读不要深一点
就是
需要多一点时间
这都是我的议册
我是觉得
这东西慢慢就会
Defuse
现在假设一个新公司。
说我要训练一个模型。
它还有很大概率
赶上来吗？
就是它可能比
前面的公司
录后两三年的时间。
像
Kimi
我是
Mimo这些项目。
都是算比较晚期出来了嘛？
Kimi还行
Mimo比较晚
对
还是有机会的嘛？
我是觉得就是
会有一段时间
大家会觉得算力不够。
然后我觉得算力慢慢。
就会起来
对我办法去参加
进程
我觉得这些上
有抱负
有决心
有办法去
去挪动资源
去建一个
大模型团队的人很多。
它会有更多什么？
我觉得如果说
大模型是一个
绝对的区分
那当然就会更多
但如果不是绝对的区分。
应该会有很多人
就是
想到
对他们的
必须你更有力的方式。
对
我就是一种自然的。
平衡状态
自然的平衡状态
对
端策模型你觉得会。
多久之后爆发吗？
这东西
跟那个
Physical AI。
会很相近嘛？
刚才也讲了嘛？
就是我觉得
资金渐渐投入
然后
科技迭代很快
也许这段时间
我说不准
但我觉得希望
对于今年的
和明年的模型精彩。
你有哪些预测
在Physical AI。
当然是很难的
创作还是很快
我还是
坚信
对我的模型能力
是帮助
这些
物理世界模型
强化
泛化的一个重要关键。
怎么落地
用什么样的
模型体制
这些事情大家都还在。
探索当中
确实GPT模型
Physical AI。
GPT is coming。
这是我可能
可以出的预测
对
当然
大语言
Coding模型这些东西。
我自己
本身在Follow。
但我自己不做
我也很难去讲
我是用的很开心
但是
我也很难讲
接下来会怎么样
刚才你说了
就是中国的
这些模型公司
那中国的机械公司。
你应该也见到很多。
你觉得美国有什么？
不一样吗？
两边
美国在做
本体的公司很少
就TESTA
跟Physical AI。
好多家公司
在做这个
本体
做本体
它可以控制的东西。
更多
可以控制
这个
模型跟软异体的整合的。
超度空间更大
然后我觉得
因为中国强大的
制造业
让产生一个
很优势的条件
可以让这些公司
做一些
在
美国不容易
做到的事情
我觉得这都是
很值得去关注
这样的垂直症
会产生什么样的
一个突破
对
我觉得还蛮有趣的。
你觉得美国
现在会不会有点
不那么重视硬件
可能是错的
也很难说
但是就是
在这个
如果说这种
软异体整合
是一个
机器人的
一个趋势
那
那没有硬件
当然是处于
被动状态
有点难讲
好多东西要考虑
包含这个
金融模式
中国
明显
就是有这个条件
可以
可以让大家
做快速的硬体
迭代
软异体整合
嗯
Cashivity Moment。
在Fysical AI。
你觉得有可能
在哪里爆发
看到一个应用
是大家很明显的知道。
就是
就是产生
巨大的经济价值
嗯
然后
也许在那个时间点。
那个应用
并没有产生经济价值。
当然去GP刚出来。
说是赔钱的
对吧？
就是大家看到的这个趋势。
然后我觉得
就会发生
那我个人觉得
这种
就是
简单的
人示范一下
怎么要的操作
这个机械
就给旧地学会
这东西
我觉得这是一个
如果这东西出现
我看到这样的一个。
这样的一个产品
我就觉得说
要
去进行某门服
Fysical AI。
所以它核心是繁华。
我觉得是繁华
就
AI的核心问题
就是解繁华的问题。
对于繁华来说
现在最重要的一个问题。
是什么？
如果只说一个
繁华的问题
在Fysical AI。
就是
怎样从这个
有限的讯号里面
学到
需要的操作
然后
应用在
一个
没有
看过的一个
的场景里面
这个是
Fysical AI。
里面要解的一个
主要的繁华问题
Observation。
对Action
这个
这个配合的繁华
让你看到一些
你看到这个
Action跟Observation。
是完成的事情
怎样快速繁华
到一个
新的Observation。
那类似的Action。
我在想
就是如果
它在Cosmos。
这套系统里学习了。
大家走向限制世界的时候。
它还是会有
怎么解决这个问题呢？
这也是一个
泛化的问题
对
就是
我们Cosmos。
想帮助
这个
Fysical AI Builder。
是透过三个方式嘛？
之前有讲的就是
Beta Data。
Beta Studying Points。
跟Beta Enviments。
那我觉得Beta Enviments。
这些东西是还没发生。
是大家都希望能
做出这个
矩阵
但还没发生
就有陆陆续续
有些Touple。
我们看到一些Wog都很不错。
那
现在比较
管用的
可能就是Beta Data。
跟Beta Studying Points。
你拿一个
懂这个
比较懂这世界
Visit怎么？
去预测Visit。
就是懂Visit可以去。
不能说真的懂Visit。
但抓到那个模式
可以去不一定
这样发生的事情
这东西
也许可以帮你
做出更好的Party。
那这东西
因为它本身的Prior。
是比较
适合泛化的
那它也许就可以帮你。
建出一个更
容易繁华的
一个Party Model。
我觉得这个
是我看到
可能短期内Cosmo Model。
可以对这个
Future Guide Builder的。
一个贡献
如果五年后
我再来采访你
你希望Cosmos。
发展到什么阶段了。
我希望五年后
如果我们
再有这个
这样的一个采访
我们可以
清楚地讲出来
究竟Moment。
是什么时候发生的。
然后是
在哪里发生
我希望可以
这个事情
是可以明确地讲出来。
就纪念几月几日
那时候就有一个
具体的时间了
对对对
More for me。
在人工智能的历史上。
你希望别人
怎么来记录你
不要讲我吧？
我觉得就是
讲Cosmos吧？
然后Cosmo
可能是一个
重要的推手
然后帮助
这些
几个重要的Future Guide Builder。
达到这个
确切并并的Moment。
我觉得这个
可能是我
会很开心的一件事情。
嗯
我还有一些快问快答。
全球范围内
一个你最喜欢的人。
食物
牛肉面
全球范围内
一个你最喜欢的地点。
好我喜欢玩曲
天气在太舒服了
你有什么喜欢的
音乐
书
电影
或者游戏吗？
书蛮多的
然后
音乐我不怎么听
游戏我已经不怎么打了。
我上次打游戏
可能都是
20几年前的事情。
能分享一本
真正改变你
或者影响过你的书。
绝神推荐的书
它是
讲Positioning的一件事情。
嗯
然后
我忘记这个书名叫什么？
很有趣的一个
心理学的书
然后
让你更加理解
问题的本质是什么？
嗯
当年轻的时候
读了很多不同的书。
对
我特别喜欢金庸小说。
那是其中一环
金庸小说有帮助
到你后面的科研
或者是
也管理吗？
倒是没有
就是
呃
里面的这些
可以体会这个金庸的。
各式各样的幻想
然后很美的一些
意境
那当然是
呃
我
推向了学
中国武术的道路
然后
呃
从中国武术里面
得到了些力量
我觉得
那都是
蛮不错的一些过程。
嗯
对于年轻的研究员。
你会有什么建议啊？
就是
比较紧张
为什么比较紧张
我现在年轻的
研究员都往往觉得。
就是
好
会不会
明年
这个
AI就
就结束啊？
就AI自训练了
然后
不要紧张
对自有信心
然后冷静下来
那个
看清楚
什么地方是
值得你投入精力
不要被这些
呃
大家的这个宣传
觉得好像自己
录越走越窄
现在研究员
进入
Physical AI是一个。
好时机
是一个狼害吗？
这是一个
好时机嘛？
就是各种机会
然后还有很多地方。
我当中做
Physical AI我比较懂。
但
这些
呃
AI的进步
那我们可以做出
更好的这些
material。
跟更好的药
这些
生物方面的
我觉得在各行各业里面。
都可以渐渐看到
这个
这个AI的影响
我觉得很多地方
都可以去投入
嗯
我们工作室叫
语言及世界工作室。
到你第一次
听到这个名字的时候。
你在想什么？
用
语言来
呃
描述这世界上
发生有趣的事
嗯
你觉得
是大模型竞争
不是由于游戏
还是世界模型
竞争不是由于游戏啊？
还说对于你来说
不是由于游戏
对别人可能是
我不清楚
你如果
你如果大家想解的东西。
一模一样
嗯
那就是由于游戏
对吧？
所以模型竞争
不应该是由于游戏。
对
因为这世界上
要被解的问题这么多。
嗯
对
然后可以提供价值的东西。
这么多
嗯
也跟喜欢的东西
不太一样
嗯
我觉得不应该是
看成是由于游戏
你有过
特别high ego的时候吗？
年轻的时候
社会的时候
对
就是我总觉得
我的算法最好
然后
对我写的paper最漂亮。
总是会这么觉得
算法重要
你需要很好的数据。
很好的infrastructure。
让你可以做快速的。
算法依赖
因为你即使
你有两种可能嘛？
一种是
你一开始算法很好。
OK
那很好
但是
你的算法不好
你有很好的data。
也很好
infrastructure。
你可以迭代
然后迭代
只要你遵循着这个。
就是很严格
纪律
然后这种控制实验。
反正你算法就越变越好。
所以
我反而觉得
迭代速度是重要的。
那迭代速度就是要靠。
强大的
no
infrastructure。
来支持
data很重要
因为
如果一个问题
可以用data解。
你就用data解就好。
就算法
因为data简单多了。
对
然后所以
不喜欢浪费力气
这个问题只要是data能解。
就收集data
就照data
然后真正不能解的。
这样就算法来解
是每一个公司都需要。
选一个自己的大模型吗？
你觉得没有必要的什么？
你如果是commodal。
你需要坚持你的电厂吗？
你每家公司
要坚持你的电厂吗？
OK
就是看
合不合合乎经济效应。
对吧？
在早期
你要做汽车工厂的时候。
当电厂不充裕的时候。
你盖个电厂
你可能可以确保
你公司是24小时运行的。
但现在这时代
你可能不需要了
对吧？
你可能跟太多
AI的开发者聊
他们每个人都是觉得。
我的AI模型是最好。
我觉得这东西
在地址上
从来没发生过
我不觉得
人跟人相处没那么容易的。
你看当初
Dario Armade。
跟San Alman。
就是合不来
对吧？
他就走了
对
然后你最近在
N-SWAPI里面。
每个人都是一模一样。
我不觉得
都是艰性的
莫非哪一天
就是你生了A
不生了B
然后B就觉得说
对吧？
然后他会不会
就带一群人走
去做个类似的东西。
对
然后
那数据大家都有
数据有
算力找你们买
算力
你只要有钱
还是买得到
对吧？
所以大家都能做
你有决心
然后你有资源
你是可以做的
所以我们用那个必要。
Cosmos
市场不能输的战争吗？
如果说
有其他公司
也做开源模型的话。
那就不是
对
什么叫战争呢？
就是我没有打算保佑。
杀死
我必须有奥务这个赛道。
不是
就是你们都得
长在我的身体上面。
NB要继续成长
VC-QAIS
一个重大的
一个市场
现在家家户都没有机器人。
但如果有机器人
我家可能会买两三个。
那每个机器人
都需要算力
那等于整个世界
最需要
最算力的需求
会大幅的成长
这个事情
如果发生的话
对Media是巨大好处。
我们的心态
不是说
想把别人给杀死
我们的心态是
我们要怎么？
去造市场
你懂我意思吗？
Coda就是造市场。
造出了
亲爱的AI的市场。
我们想的是
怎么造出
下一个大的市场
那你说
是
不能输的战场吗？
我觉得
也不是
因为是全新的东西。
对
我们有个任何人竞争是吧？
就是
功力
带着大家一起
把市场建出来
然后
你买这个机器人赚钱。
你做这个卡森埃卷。
赚钱
那
这个
东西会需要一些算力。
有赚钱
那当然会有公司
烟发自己的晶片
他也会赚钱
但这个市场就起来。
原本是Nothing。
老黄会分享类似的观点吗？
对 经常说
经常说
造市场
而不是存量竞争
对
你读他的书就会发现。
他讲说
我们就叫做这种
GISO billion dollar business。
什么叫GISO billion dollar business。
就是现在不是个business。
但以后成功后会变Billion。
嗯
如果现在已经有人在做。
可能就不值得做
这是一种拥抱风险。
还是一种抵抗风险。
还是一个de-risk吗？
这是一个de-risk。
我们做事
运化是很 risky的。
全部
就是库达那时候
是很 risky 的这件事情。
等于是赔本在卖
嗯
对吧？
我们因为装库达
我们整个GPU的价格都比别人高。
同样的flops。
我们就是比别人高。
因为我们要支援
这个pogmanability。
嗯
对吧？
你不这么做
你做这件事情很 risky。
你不做这件事情
更加 risky。
对
你不做那件事情
别人做了的话
对于你们来说就
对
非常的有风险
嗯
不做这件事情的话。
就是你的东西
就渐渐变commodity。
嗯
你还要从老皇身上。
学到什么没有
我都尽量很用心在学习。
他怎么去跑其他东西。
然后从里面去
应用在跑cosmo。
为什么其他公司都说。
CEO不应该是最努力的人。
但是你们公司
CEO是最努力的人。
对
是
好 这我也不懂
但它
It works。
I cannot。
对吧？
这件事情没有绝对。
它现在的驱动力是什么呀？
驱动力就是take your families。
哦
对
做AI者真的是很有趣的一件事情。
你尤其是站在它角度里面。
看到它的贡献改变世界。
我觉得是很有成就的一件事情。
不愧是教主
是的
嗯